[Music]
hello everyone if you're a fan of SCP
explained you'll know that we regularly
post interesting questions in our
community tab asking for responses from
you are dear fans these have ranged from
questions about specific anomalies like
scp-096 or your suggestions on how we
should actually kill
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile
we've even asked you which anomalous
Powers you'd want to have and pose your
questions directly to scp-343 also known
as God and of course the terrifying and
Infamous Scarlet King but in our latest
Community question asking you about
hypothetical crossovers between the SCP
Foundation and the weird wild Multiverse
of all fiction you truly outdid yourself
with thousands upon thousands of
responses and we thought rather than
just making one video selecting our
favorites we turn each of our favorites
into whole videos and how are we going
to do that that's where this wonderful
state-of-the-art Gizmo comes into play
you may remember the animatron 6000 are
incredibly Advanced artificial
intelligence driven supercomputer
designed specifically to run simulations
for the SCP Foundation we fed this
computer data from countless SCP
Foundation experiments and cross-tests
and all the data from your suggestions
this will allow the fine folks at the
SCP Foundation to explore any anomalous
hypothetical without risking the lives
of Staff members or civilians this
brings us to our first simulation
suggested in a huge number of comments
could scp-682 be contained within the
back rooms for those not in the know the
back rooms is an internet urban legend
that spiraled into a full-blown
phenomenon it's built on the premise
that if you're not careful and enter
certain specific circumstances you can
no clip out of our reality and enter a
terrifying multi-level alternate reality
where you're stalked by a variety of
bizarre and frightening creatures this
could be a complete nightmare for your
average person but how would it play out
if scp-682 the endlessly angry hard to
destroy reptile found its way inside
also for another backrooms related
surprise stick around until the end of
the video in the meantime though let's
boot up the animatron and test this new
scenario the worst had happened again
scp-682 had busted out of containment
during a cross-test and started making a
beeline for the nearest populated area
several helicopters containing heavily
armed MTF new seven hammer down members
were in Hot Pursuit attempting to slow
The Vicious reptile down with targeted
sniper fire at its legs but it seems
that these efforts were all for naught
scp-682 had already reached the defunct
industrial district on the edge of a
nearby City and if the Beast managed to
actually reach a populated area all hell
would break loose that's when they
pulled out the heavy weapon Rings
miniguns mounted to the helicopter
Unleashed A Reign of Hellfire down onto
scp-682 however 682 managed to dodge
most of the bullets and simply tank the
rest command authorized the use of heavy
ornaments the helicopter's missile
launchers they pick up the pieces
afterwards once scp-682 was back in
containment however the reptile had
plans of its own it charged into a
nearby abandoned chemical plant to avoid
the gunfire from above this was exactly
what hammerdown wanted the helicopters
circled around the chemical plant and
Unleashed a barrage of powerful
incendiary missiles blowing the plant to
Kingdom come in hopes of dragging an
incapacitated 682 out of the rubble
afterwards but when the smoke had
cleared and only the rubble was left 682
was nowhere to be seen even for the
hardcore operatives of hammerdown this
caused an anxiety Spike had it tunneled
into the ground had it adapted to the
attack by turning invisible or getting
tiny to escape it done all the these
things before or after all the deranged
attempts at putting scp-682 in the
ground had some light firebombing killed
the monster whatever the case they need
to search in case scp-682 popped up
somewhere else and started causing Havoc
if it was still alive
probably was they couldn't rest on their
Laurels until they'd found it again
meanwhile
scp-682 woke up it felt groggy and
irritated its body resting against an
unpleasant soggy carpet it licked the
carpet the moisture had the distinct
flavor of humans spinal fluid which 682
had tasted many times before the sickly
yellow walls and incessant buzzing from
the fluorescent lights up above were
nauseating and it gave 682 a nagging
headache this only made 682's default
emotion blistering rage and hatred even
worse it began walking around exploring
this strange spatial anomalous
environment was this more of that
frustrating Foundation trickery another
one of those purile cross-tests the last
thing 682 remembered was running at one
of the walls in the chemical plant a
wall that in hindsight seemed darker
than all the others but rather than
shattering through the brickwork it was
here now in this strange tacky Lobby
that never seemed to end it was like a
kaleidoscope of Mt 1990s office Kitsch
endless worthless yellow walls arranged
like some Labyrinthian nonsensical maze
leading nowhere and devoid of all life
as scp-682 wandered through it and of
course
scp-682 found it disgusting it was only
on level zero and already 682 hated the
back rooms just as much as it hated R
Dimension someone or something had to
pay for the crime of inconveniencing it
this way and it would happily turn this
whole dimension inside out just to find
some beings to kill inside it yes that
would be great fun
scp-682 began its frantic search for an
exit evolving an innate sonar ability
and picking up speeds that would be
impossible for human beings this is the
part where most people would go mad or
die from Hunger or thirst
scp-682 not so much it could keep
searching and searching and searching
until the ours burned out in the sky it
would find its prey somehow and when it
did it would put them through hell and
as it turned out this new universe
rewarded 682's dog's stubbornness
because when it passed through a
seemingly random hallway after hours of
searching it was in a different place
entirely this place looked like some
huge abandoned warehouse complex with
water shining off the ground if 682 had
more advanced knowledge of the back
rooms he would have known this was level
one but the only number scp-682 cared
about was body count and in that regard
it would find level one to be a vast
Improvement two groups of humans had
established bases in this level of the
back rooms the major Explorer group a
faction of professional backrooms
Travelers who maintained their base
Alpha on this level and the back room's
non-aligned trade group a commercial
group whose primary base is an economic
Hub on this very level a Fortified
city-like Area with a population of 412
which would a few hours after 682's
appearance be a population of zero but
before all of that it felt like grabbing
a bite at the diner Tom's Diner is a
refuge for many people trapped in the
back rooms a casual eatering nestled
into the cold Warehouse environment of
level one where people could get a warm
meal from Tom a former cook who's been
trapped in the back room for years
scp-682 was eager to be part of this
Grand tradition but the hard to destroy
reptile decided to Buck the trend a
little by just devouring Tom himself
from there decided to launch its rage
fueled offensive against the various
humanoid inhabitants of the level both
the major Explorer group base Alpha and
the back room's non-aligned trade Group
trade keep were heavily fortified
against the kind of entities these folks
had gotten used to facing in the back
rooms but they were completely
unprepared for a creature of
scp-682's sheer power intelligence
endurance and ferocity the SCP
Foundation had been studying the
creature for decades with Farm more
resources than either of these two
backrooms bound groups and they still
had a hard time keeping the Beast
consistently contained sadly for the
great Bastion of human hope in the back
rooms
scp-682 swept through both outposts in a
matter of hours killing everyone there
without an ounce of remorse the only
person there it took its time with was
the final human being left in the
decimated remains of the major explorers
group base Alpha it grabbed the man by
the throat and squeezed asking with its
guttural growling voice you were you
when your dead Brethren allied with the
SCP Foundation despite a sphere the
Explorer told 682 that he had never
heard of the SCP Foundation nor did he
know what kind of entity 682 was
then what is this place tell me and I
might give you a quick death the
Explorer gave as good a response as he
could 682 was trapped in the back rooms
a multi leveled interdimensional
nightmare filled with dangerous
creatures that made 682 curious
dangerous creatures that could make an
interesting challenge 682 asked the
Explorer how could access these other
levels and find these creatures and the
Explorer explained that through
exploring these levels enough anyone
could no clip into the next one it
really was that simple with that 682
knew all it needed to know and
carelessly murdered the final human
being of level 1. it had killed so many
humans over its long and twisted life it
was no different from breathing air now
and utterly perfunctory action it was
eager to discover these other creatures
on the lower levels and teach them a new
level of fear they'd never experienced
682 stormed the Halls until it achieved
the next successful no clip into level 2
which manifested as a series of old
dilapidated maintenance tunnels that
seemed to stretch on for millions of
miles wonderful there were humans here
too apparently but who cared about
this was the first level to feature a
smorgasbord of entities ripe for The
Killing It sped through the tunnels
teeth and fangs born eager to deal death
with gleeful abandon the first entities
had encountered in the expansive tunnels
of level 2 were a collection of beings
known as crawlers insect-like creatures
infected with an extremely aggressive
fungal growth just getting close to them
could present an active risk to humans
not so much for a creature that could
easily regenerate after being tossed
into the Sun as the creatures tried to
Lunge as cp682 simply crushed and
devoured them with little effort they
tasted a little stale on account of a
fungus but the chewiness was pleasing
hopefully there would be more
challenging foes down in the tunnel than
these mere insects
scp-682 thought to itself while
journeying deeper into the endless
network of tunnels soon enough scp-682
ventured into a section of the tunnel
engulfed in total darkness its eyes
quickly adjusted developing Immaculate
night vision that's when it spotted
another creature sharing this little
slice of Darkness with it a pair of
floating glowing eyes an almost
cartoonish teeth grinning like some
maniacal Looney Tune this is an entity
known as a Smiler and they're a
terrifying threat to any humans
venturing through the back rooms
scp-682 wasn't impressed it began a
perfect adaptation for the situation its
body began to Glow emitting incredible
levels of both heat and light carving
through the darkness of the tunnel and
causing The Smiler to emit a terrible
piercing shriek the sheer heat of this
new ability melted sections of the level
2 tunnels around
scp-682 when the light finally dimmed
down to slightly more reasonable levels
where The Smiler once stood was instead
a fizzling black Scorch Mark another
creature had painfully bitten the dust
and scp-682 was starting to have some
fun it took off further down into the
tunnels looking forward to finding its
next victim sadly for scp-6 82 it
wouldn't get to kill the next set of
victims a group of four child facelings
spooky faceless little girls who like to
cut apart their typical human victims
with small objects were waiting a little
further down the pipe however when they
felt scp-682 approaching they almost
sensed the power and cruelty of the bees
coming towards them even being little
monsters themselves game recognized game
and they knew that they needed to get
the hell out of there before the monster
arrived they climbed between the pipes
on the tunnel walls and skittered off
into hiding places deep in the dark
lucky for them
scp-682 passed them and just kept going
what would be the point in wasting time
on these little morsels when there were
apparently so many other creatures to
Massacre down here next scp-682 came
across a truly pathetic creature
something that the mighty reptile
honestly felt a little embarrassed even
interacting with it was a creature known
as a clump a strange bundle of living
limbs that will move at Great speeds and
attack packets usually human targets
they try to do the same to scp-682
maniacally flailing its many Twisted
limbs 682 killed it in a single Stomp
and moved on filling its own
psychological equivalent of pity but not
that much of it not long after mercy
killing the clump
scp-682 came face to face with a series
of hounds mutant humanoids who travel on
all fours behaving in a wolf-like
fashion this would of course be the
stuff of nightmares for your average
human being but would far more likely
put a being like the hard to destroy
reptile to sleep with sheer boredom
humans acting like dogs that makes them
even more worthless the creature thought
as it charged forwards and began tearing
the group of hounds to shreds minutes
later it was splitting off into an
adjoining tunnel searching for more easy
entertainment but the deeper scp-682
made its way into the bowels of level 2
the more it approached a truly
horrifying realization the cree
creatures it was slaughtering here were
even more boring than the ones the SCP
Foundation ceaselessly threw at it back
on its native reality or at least the
reality where they'd contained it back
in that world it had faced giant flaming
demigods with swords hotter than the sun
it had faced some pale shrieking
monstrosity that didn't seem to die no
matter what the reptile threw at it
there was the dark gooey old man The
Immortal Warrior from the Black Coffin
and even the all-devouring bunny rabbit
here it was killing the same wretched
selection of beasts again and again a
truly pitiful offering was this really
the best this world had to offer
incidentally the next creature it found
was literally known as wretches by the
human inhabitants of the back rooms they
were fleshy zombie-like creatures that
scp-682 figured the sarkists back home
might enjoy they couldn't believe that
it was thinking fondly of that old place
while it carved the monsters to ribbons
with its claws it missed its old enemies
like Dr bright Dr klaff and even that
irritating yellow blob of snot the more
tried to take its mind off the old world
by killing its way through this Ant Farm
of endless tunnels the more it found
itself waxing nostalgic for example
there were the play goblins impish
little creatures with masks like that of
a plague doctor 682 found itself
thinking almost fondly about scp-049
while at listlessly ate the tiny
mischievous creatures like a depressed
person binging an extra large pack of
chips even their tiny squeaks as they
crunch between the reptile's terrible
teeth gave it no joy what a bleak turn
of events this had all turned out to be
as it wandered through the infinite
tunnels killing creatures and even
humans as it found them
scp-682 made a quiet promise to itself
somehow some way it would make its way
back to the universe it so recently
departed it would leave the back rooms
no matter how many levels a quiet
burning husk and return to the world of
Fools and
had taken for granted all this time a
visit to the back rooms had taught the
hard to destroy reptile and All Too
Human lesson sometimes you don't know
what you have until it's gone sure the
SCP Foundation may have tried to kill it
in a new bizarre and increasingly
sadistic way every single day but that
variety was the spice of life it would
return home someday it knew that much
but of course a lot of creatures and
people would need to die before then but
if that's what it took one so be it
scp-682 licked its dagger-like fangs and
kept crawling a beloved mentally
unstable masked vigilante once said I'm
not trapped in here with you you're
trapped in here with me and this exact
sentiment was shared by scp-682 the hard
to destroy reptile as it traversed the
almost Limitless liminal hell known as
the back rooms it'd been little more
than a standard Chase and secure mission
for the mobile task forces pursuing
scp-682 after its latest deadly
Containment Breach until the vicious
lizard made its way into an abandoned
warehouse and no clipped its way into a
new reality as the SCP Foundation are
still desperately searching for the
missing Beast back in our native reality
682 has been discovering whole new
vistas of violence first it found itself
in the endless yellow Halls of level
zero where if the madness doesn't get
you the starvation and thirst will well
unless you're in an anomalous reptilian
Abomination that can seemingly adapt to
any situation 160 to escape this gaudy
Purgatory it found its way into level
one an endless Warehouse full of equal
parts monsters and hapless human
settlers all of whom it decimated in a
single bloody afternoon then on to level
2 the pipe rooms where it faced a bevy
of beasts that it eagerly put into the
ground and that brings us up to now and
by extension on to level three
scp-682 Spilled Out into another section
of long industrial hallways it didn't
know how it had gotten in and honestly
it didn't really care at this point all
it needed to do was keep moving forward
and killing as it pleased and it seemed
there were plenty of creatures down here
to kill that being said this level had a
certain energy to it and we mean that
literally 682 is incredibly sensitive
well senses allowed it to detect an
incredibly powerful electrical field
emanating from this level and from the
sounds of machines humming all around it
traveling down great bundles of wires
and pipes bound to the walls it knew
that this level must have been attached
to a generator of truly incredible size
it charged forward weaving around the
different hallways at freakish speeds
searching for the next thing it could
blast into Oblivion and thankfully it
was able to find its first Target soon
enough a nest of creatures known as
death moths these were huge fluttering
moths of freakish size congregating
around a glowing electrical outlet
intriguing
scp-682 decided to approach and
introduce itself after all they looked
like pretty easy prey 682 would regret
this oversight while the male death
moths are pretty much harmless the
female Death moths have an extremely
potent defense mechanism as scp-682
approached the creatures began swarming
and spraying acid onto its reptilian
this was painful and irritating for 682
of course but if any entity on Earth is
pretty accustomed to dealing with large
quantities of powerful acid by now it's
scp-682 its skin quickly healed from the
acidic Onslaught and it developed a
powerful counter adaption a long sticky
frog-like tongue which it used to Devour
the nest full of death moths and move
along to its next Target it continued
exploring level 3 a number of hallways
were marked off with metal bars another
very familiar site for scp-682 so for
simplicity's sake it just kept itself to
the unobstructed paths that's where it
soon ran into another life form standing
around like a Sitting Duck in one of the
level's many anomalous hallways it was
just another human in a similar outfit
to all those major Explorer group
weaklings it had destroyed earlier
strangely even when scp-682 entered the
hallway with it it didn't seem to react
properly it just made vacantly stared
off into space stumbling around
awkwardly 682 bemused whipped this
random disoriented stranger in the chest
with its tail sending him sailing into
the nearby wall it was at this point
that something strange happened the
force of the strike caused the man's
clothes and also skin to disintegrate
leaving something entirely different
underneath
scp-682 had no idea what was going on
but I knew that it hated it this was its
first encounter with a creature known as
a skin stealer it would be natural for a
human being to be terrified of an
Abomination like this an apex predator
like 682 on the other hand it barely
even found the Skin Stealer interesting
with a single stomp from its clawed
reptilian foot the creature was very
very dead and scp-682 continued its
Journey Through the bowels of level 3.
it found itself drawn to whatever the
source of all the energy was if it had
one single Source it was almost as
though the entire level was one gigantic
Predator powering the rest of the back
rooms and if there was electricity
perhaps there were other humans in here
to kill
scp-682 liked that idea very much indeed
however while making its way down a
slightly wider hallway one that it had
previously believed was completely
uninhabited it was suddenly ambushed by
a group of mysterious attackers a number
of tall gray creatures with long clawing
arms and unclear facial features stepped
away from the wall these entities are
known as the dollars Ambush Predators
native to the back rooms they normally
run away from threats but considering
the number of them congregated in the
hall around
scp-682 perhaps they felt a little more
confident about taking down their prey
in a group but they'd made a grave
miscalculation it would not matter
whether there was one dollar or a
thousand dollars in the battle between
them an scp-682 they would always always
always
be the prey but lucky for them while
they weren't aware of this immutable
fact yet
scp-682 was more than happy to give them
a first-hand education while the dullers
tried their best to claw into
scp-682's thick leathery hide the
creature decided to employ a new ability
it had stolen from the female Death
moths several new glands developed all
over 682's body Each of which produced a
fine mist of highly concentrated acid
soon enough the dollars were howling in
pain and melting away into dull gray
puddles on the ground never to
reconstitute again that's what you get
for trying to climb up the food chain
folks it never ends well unless you're
682 that is after disposing of the
dollars which in 682's own humble
opinion had more than earned that title
by indeed being extremely dull it
decided to continue its search for some
of the power sources is on this level
perhaps it could harness this ability
for its own benefit but it was
interrupted by what is frankly one of
the grossest enemies in all of the back
rooms the bursters and if even hearing
the name makes you feel a little sick
then you're correctly primed for what
you're about to encounter they're
humanoid creatures that walk around on
all fours with its back legs grotesquely
stretched out into the shape of a dog's
hind legs but that's nothing compared to
the bursters truly diabolical back knee
all over the creature's back you can see
huge calloused cysts that contain a
potent and noxious acid sure the acid is
only about as dangerous as the stuff
produced by female Death moths but in
our humble opinion the method of acid
delivery is far more repulsive and that
makes bursters less desirable to
encounter a small group of them
skittered out of the darkness towards
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile also
found them disgusting though now that we
think about it scp-682 thinks all forms
of life are disgusting so we suppose
that it's all relative however when they
began to burst their backs and coat 682
in their horrible pus they perhaps
earned the rarely given label of extra
disgusting from this living embodiment
of reptilian hate 682 quickly retaliated
by clawing the horrid creatures to death
which I think we can all agree is a good
and well-deserving ending for the vile
little beasts we would have done the
same thing the next enemies that 682
encountered weren't nightmarish
creatures but in fact were human beings
stationed in the major Explorer group's
base gamma the third most important base
in all of the back rooms they were on
high alert after losing contact with
base Alpha several days before having no
idea that everyone at that base had been
slaughtered by scp-682 a faith that if
they weren't tremendously lucky they
would soon share but they had little
more than luck on their side this time
scp-68 22 sighted the base on the end of
a long hallway there was even a person
standing at the other end of the hall
seemingly blissfully aware of the
encroaching presence of one of the SCP
foundation's most dangerous and
formidable captives 682 loved killing
humans most of all they weren't just
dumb animals they had the intellectual
capacity to actually appreciate the life
that was being ripped away from them and
it made the whole act even more
pleasurable for
scp-682 it set its sights on the
ignorant major Explorer group member
leaning against the distant wall and
decided to charge for him claws extended
and fangs barred this would be such easy
prey until the moment when someone in
the distance yelled now in the seemingly
defenseless human turned around and
pulled the lever on the wall suddenly
the whole hallway was electrified
sending millions of volts coursing
through
scp-682's writhing body this whole thing
had been an elaborate trap the humans at
base gamma hadn't survived this long in
the back rooms by being stupid the more
technically Savvy members had rewired
some of the hallways to channel the
immense energy of the generators and Fry
any unfortunate entities that tried to
use these hallways to break into base
gamma there was one big problem though
scp-682 wasn't just any unfortunate
entity while it did initially look like
electricity might fry the Beast it
gradually began channeling the
electricity into its own body and
developing the capacity to re-gift this
electricity to the people who so kindly
provided it
scp-682 now a crackling conduit of
electricity leaped from the shocking
hallway and into base gamma soon enough
it had fatally electrocuted all 300
members of the major Explorer group
posted in base gamma and returned to its
Baseline state level 3 had grown
tiresome now it seemed that there were
no more exciting new creatures to
Massacre as a result 682 slid into a
nearby elevator and went down where a
new level awaited this was how scp-682
got to level 4. and level 4 was not what
the hard to destroy reptile expected in
contrast to the industrial nightmare of
the previous few levels level 4 was like
a limitless office block with all the
furniture ripped out while for some this
might represent the crushing existential
banality of office life and how the
wheels of capitalism inevitably work us
all to death
scp-682 had never worked in an office
before so it didn't really have the
proper cultural reference points to
appreciate this more abstract kind of
fear it wanted Monsters to kill 682
spent approximately six days searching
around the hellscape that is level four
not discovering a single person or
entity while it was there it was
honestly the most stressed that scp-682
had felt since coming here the Beast was
almost tempted to unscrew a light bulb
from above draw a little face on
begin referring to it as Wilson and then
kill it 682 felt the closest emotion it
could manage to immense gratitude when
it cited the glowing green of a distant
exit sign at the end of a long hallway
finally a way out onto another level
hopefully this one would have more
creatures to slaughter welcome
scp-682 to level 5.
scp-682 didn't really know what to
expect from the next level of the back
rooms after all it all seemed pretty
random so far but it definitely didn't
expect to see a classy well-appointed
Hotel on the other end of the hallway
scp-682 had never seen the Stanley
Kubrick Masterpiece The Shining nor read
the book it was based on by Master of
horror Stephen King but if it had who
would probably have drawn the comparison
instead it was already busy tearing
through the ornate Halls looking for new
prey to slaughter the first unexpected
encounter was with a small cat that
casually wandered out into the hallway
right into front of it the cat who
didn't seem threatened by a cp682 said
hi I'm Samantha you got any meat you can
lend me I'll tell you your fortune if
you do
scp-682 was frankly baffled it took a
moment to formulate a reply
[Music]
creature you have no idea what you're
dealing with do you I'm going to bring
this place to ruin and destroy all who
reside within 682 said Salah no meat
then 682 growled and swiped at the cat
with its claws luckily she was able to
dodge the cat tutted and patted away
into the darkness muttering they'll
bother the Beast instead jerk this
peaked scp-682's interest a beast to say
sounds important sounds powerful finally
a worthy opponent our battle shall be
legendary and with renewed Vigor as
cp682 began prowling the halls of the
back rooms searching for this Beast to
defeat and Destroy but to begin with
things were grievously disappointing one
of the first monsters on this opulent
hotel level that the hard to destroy
reptile faced were diminutive little
rodents known as death rats which were
effectively slightly larger than normal
rats with little horns
scp-682 stomped them all with ease its
thoughts dripping with disdain for their
truly pathetic weakness what kind of
Hotel allows itself to be filled with
rats even by human standards this would
be disgraceful soon after scp-682
encountered a few familiar foes female
Death moths and Hounds all is easy to
kill as they were before
scp-682 didn't understand the feline
promised that there was a beast down
here was it hiding from the mighty
reptile like a filthy coward
worthless but it was in the depths of
this cynicism that scp-682 encountered a
growler first it heard the sound of
animalistic growling projected directly
into its mind getting louder and louder
by the moment then as the growling grew
in volume 682 heard the thunderous
footsteps of a huge quadruped getting
closer 66 you wondered as the Roaring
became almost deafening whether this
sounded heralded the approach of the
Beast however the second the monster
actually turned the corner and came into
view 682 had to suppress the urge to
laugh it was one of the most absurd
things it had ever seen it looked like a
giant pile of pipe cleaners in every
color imaginable arranged into a vaguely
four-legged structure this was the
monster producing all that psychic
racket
pathetic
scp-682 resolved in that moment to show
the monster how it was done
scp-682 immediately evolved its own
psychica mission capacitors within its
brain and projected the message you are
a worthless little creature directly
into the simple Mind Of The Growler it
began to quake in horror at the booming
of 682's voice in its brain what was
this terrifying new creature it didn't
understand and just like that 682 who
had grown bored of this once cited
psychic battle turned up the strength of
the psychic being by a factor of 50. the
sudden psychic blast was so powerful
that The Growler collapsed to the ground
and burst into flames burning itself
away into nothingness in a matter of
moments just as weak as 682 had expected
hopefully the Beast would provide a
greater challenge because this was just
getting sad
scp-682 shook off the disappointment and
continued running through the halls of
the hotel eventually after passing
through some dull dance hall called the
Beverly room 682 found itself running
through a hallway full of long portraits
every person in the portraits had a
strange Twisted grin on their face not
that this even registered to scp-682
what did occur to 682 though was the
figure that suddenly materialized in the
hallway in front of it it was a strange
figure to be sure an entity in a suit
with a large Blue cuttlefish for a head
the creature cleared its throat and
began to speak well hello there you're
new here aren't you such an interesting
creature you've been making some trouble
on the other levels haven't you
not that it's any of my business on the
contrary dear sir I like the cut of your
jib how would you feel about joining me
in the hotel business it is an easy to
manage this Dimension by myself after
all how about you and I come into my
office we can work out the terms of our
682 lunch forward and unceremoniously
devoured the creature's head allowing
its dapperly dressed body to fall limply
to the ground dead
scp-682 grunted annoyed by the
distraction the creature had provided it
had better things to do this Beast has
got to be around here somewhere it seen
that the foundation was all but rid of
scp-682 after an unlikely glitch in
reality sent the hard to destroy reptile
deep into a limitless interdimensional
Abyss known simply as the back rooms
this meant that the standard reality
also known as the front rooms was safe
from one of the most dangerous monsters
in existence but that didn't mean the
anomaly was neutralized
scp-682 had been slowly but surely
making its way through every level of
the back rooms and taking out its
aggression on any living thing that
crossed its path well except for Jerry
there was something about the entity
which resembled blue hyacinth macaw that
had made it tolerable to scp-682 which
was rare for the reptile as it
infamously regarded most other life
forms as disgusting and worthy only to
be destroyed Jerry had been frightened
Away by an encounter with the archers of
level 10 and ever since
scp-682 had been looking a little guy
this search eventually led the creature
to backtrack through the suburbs of
level 9 and enter level 11. the
presumably infinite City this was the
largest settlement that scp-682 had seen
in the back rooms and whether or not it
found its avian companion it was eager
to cause some Havoc among the locals and
speaking of the locals what a sorry
sight they were countless facelings were
acting like ordinary humans going about
their day strolling down the sidewalks
and entering buildings seemingly with no
reason other than to humor the themed
environment a few of the facelings were
even walking hounds on leashes in a
grotesque pantomime of a dog walker 682
was infuriated somehow in its seemingly
infinite ways of causing the creature
distress the back rooms had managed to
combine the two things that annoyed it
most the so-called civilized creatures
of its native reality and the equally
disgusting entities that dwelled within
the back rooms unable to stand to look
at this any longer
scp-682 went on a violent Rampage
attacking every entity in sight its
previous subjective of seeking Jerry no
longer mattered to it as the anomalies
discussed for every part of this
alternate reality overwhelmed all of its
thoughts if 682 found itself starring in
Pixar's Inside Out All the emotions in
its mind would be variations of disgust
as the body started to pile up
scp-682 began to sense something in the
airwaves at this level it soon adapted a
long-range radio antenna in order to
better pick up the frequency the voice
on the other was calm and sounded like a
middle-aged human male you're listening
to radio back rooms the voice said if
you're just tuning in now welcome to
talking with Ralph I'm your host Ralph
there you are
scp-682 said triangulating the radio
signal with internal senses this Ralph
character was going to be next to die
well he would be next if nothing else
with a dumb look about it got in the way
and in the back rooms the chances were
high that a new pathetic creature for
scp-682 to destroy would be around every
corner either way 682 marked the new
Waypoint on its mental map and started
to zero in on Ralph's location looks
like we got ourselves a brand new entity
in level 11 Ralph's voice echoed in
scp-682 skull I'll be giving away a free
time slot to whichever faction bags the
Beast Within the next 12 hours
scp-682 realized almost immediately that
it must have been the new entity that
Ralph was referring to it was familiar
with the idea of factions within the
back rooms because of its previous
encounters with the major explorers
group but now the situation threatened
to get interesting maybe there would be
some factions here with actual combat
training on par with the mobile task
forces could these new factions pose a
challenge to such a powerful ketter
class anomaly 682 heard the buzzing of
tiny propellers overhead and saw a group
of surveillance drones flying towards it
with cat-like agility it leaped into the
air and swatted the drones with its
Limbs and Claws the cheap hunks of
carbon fiber were shattered easily
halfway across the city several members
of the Drone surveillance Squad were
throwing their headsets on the ground in
frustration with one faction having
missed its chance the next was quick to
arrive five cool teens on bikes and
skateboards rolled up to the end of the
street they were all dressed in 80s
fashion for some reason check it out
that's one righteous reptile said one of
the teens gnarly said another 682
cringed even with its limited
understanding of human culture it could
tell that 80s Nostalgia was overplayed
and that the era of 90s and 2000s
Nostalgia would soon arrive and what
better way to hasten it than getting
these troubled teens off the street just
don't ask where they went after that
another so-called faction down an
scp-682 was already feeling uncontested
so far these humans were even less
intimidating than the entities this was
a bit mind-boggling to scp-682
considering that the foundation was made
up of humans and they had managed to bag
several much scarier anomalies than
anything in the back rooms naturally
scp-682 included itself among that
number the Radio Studio we're talking
with Ralph was broadcasting from was
getting ever closer taking a slight
detour the reptile tore straight through
level 11's neg base of operations once
again the Explorers within proved to be
no match for the creature it emerged on
the other side of the building back into
the city streets and was immediately
confronted with several new explorers
these humans weren't exactly 80s
fashionable opting instead for tactical
gear and long black cloaks they had a
haunted look about them and each carried
a mighty spear sinner they shouted in
unison the eyes of Argos are upon you
SCP 682 pounced and made short work of
them but paused warily when it noticed
the presence of a slightly taller
humanoid that had been standing behind
the group who was dressed the same as
the humans but it had an aura of Mythic
Fury the humanoid had no eyes but
somehow
scp-682 could feel itself being watched
as if from all places at once it was
unsettling for the creature as it felt
like being back at the foundation
contained in a vatic acid while a
science lab full of researchers watched
and judged yes judged that was the
feeling and scp-682 knew it all too well
the humanoid stepped forward brandishing
its spear what was it with this place
and Spears
scp-682 wondered the powerful entity it
had on level 7 had also wielded the
spear was that weapon meant to be some
indication that this one was just as
tough I am all seeing Argos and I have
seen that your sins are innumerable said
the humanoid entity Argos lunged forward
thrusting with its spear towards scp-682
the reptile received the brunt of the
strike and was launched backward without
even giving 682 time to recover Argos
thrust its spear through the creature
pinning it to the concrete Sinners must
be punished Argos bellowed pushing the
spear deeper into the reptile's body
scp-682 struck back with a bite but to
its surprise Argo seemed to have an
impossibly high tolerance for pain and
its wounds seemed to be healing almost
as soon as they opened this told 682
that close range attacks wouldn't get
this entity spear out of its back it
needed to get the freaky humanoid out of
spear range and then hit back with a
reach weapon of its own
tapping once again into the radio
frequencies 682 levied a blast of
concussive Sonic energy from its body
while this didn't damage Argos it did
achieve the intended effect of knocking
The Entity a few feet back
scp-682 used this chance to get a bit of
distance and readied its next weapon its
own reptilian Tale Now elongated and
equipped with a sharp blade at the end
in terms of reach as cp682's tailwhip
outclassed argos's spear the battle was
on now 682 swung its powerful blade in
an attempt to cut through the enemy's
weapon but it seemed that the spear had
the same regenerative abilities as its
wielder you're not human
scp-682 taunted Argos you're even more
disgusting you are a sinner Argos
replied regeneration was one of scp-682
strong suits too and the spear wounds
that Argos had given it had already
recovered using the bladed whip of its
tail as scp-682 kept Argos and his spear
out of Close Quarters it continued to
slash The Entity but the wounds were
healing too quickly to leave an
impression Argos was also skilled enough
with his spear that he began to deflect
the Whip and Advance towards 682 it was
time to try something crazy so crazy it
just might work Argo stopped in his
tracks as suddenly
scp-682 was nowhere to be found the
reptile had become effectively invisible
and this was because it had adapted to
counter argos's true Vision now encased
in a ghostly Aura of sin cloaking energy
scp-682 maneuvered around Argos and
prepared to finish it off if you're like
me then this won't bring you down but it
will hurt Argos and I will enjoy it
calling upon the memories of the acid
Vats back at the foundation
scp-682 secreted a powerful acid across
its entire body and left onto our Argos
is back the thing about Spears is while
they are ideal for engaging the opponent
at a distance they were far less useful
if that same opponent was grappling your
limbs with his weapon rendered unusable
Argos was now locked in a battle of
endurance with scp-682 it had generated
the most powerful acid it could generate
potent enough to even cause a bit of
damage to itself it's over Argos
scp-682 chuckled you may be good at
fighting but only one of us has spent
years being contained within a caustic
prison you lose
scp-682 held down Argos for as long as
it took for the acid to fully immobilize
him the entity had struggled to break
free but 682 was able to continually
grow strong enough to tighten its grip
but the boss of this level destroyed
scp-682 continued towards the radio
tower ah
congratulations you Ralph said over the
radio your win lizard man how about you
and I have a nice peaceful chat not
having any of this
scp-682 beamed its own words into the
radio station along the same frequency
tell me how to get to the next level and
I'll consider sparing you but only
because you are that worthless haha I
Dare You Lizard Man Ralph responded
nervously Ralph directed scp-682 to a
specific window inside of one of the
nearby skyscrapers when scp-682 opened
this window it was immediately
transported into a cramped white room
with a table that had a single chair
nearby this was level 12
scp-682 was most assuredly going back
for Ralph later yet another level seemed
specifically created to play on the
on-ui of The Human Condition which was
something that 682 still had no frame of
reference for humans were afraid of the
things 682 thought to itself it waited
in this white room for what felt like
several hours until it was eventually no
clipped back into level 11.
scp-682 roared loud enough to shatter
the glass windows on several buildings
in the infinite City it charged out of
the skyscraper and onto the roof of a
nearby apartment building which just so
happened to be another surface with no
clip capabilities 682 never got to hear
a response back from the talk radio host
before it fell several stories down into
another level of the back rooms entirely
level 13 an apartment building that
while not technically infinite was
presumed to have a very high number of
floors the hallways were more cramped
than the hotel on level 5 so scp-682
shrunk itself a bit to avoid getting
stuck they gridded its teeth and
prepared for the usual routine three two
one a clump a female moth and a Hound
came slinking down the hallway like a
random encounter in a jrpg
scp-682 hated these backrooms entities
so very much and could barely fathom why
they could stand each other it seemed
that no matter what level these hostile
entities appeared the Goon Squad only
ever attacked creatures that weren't
native to the back rooms without further
deliberation 682 ran the Three Stooges
over trampling them with its Superior
Powers it was more than done taking
small fry seriously and that included
Curly Larry and Moe as it wandered
through the Halls
scp-682 started to hear the droning easy
listening music which pervaded this
entire level it was the sort of sound
that humans used in elevators and
grocery stores places where the dull
mundanity of life was meant to serve as
a comfort and yet it seemed to be the
soundtrack of the back room's latest
hellish level in a way 682 started to
feel pity for the humans trapped here
not because their suffering was a bad
thing from its perspective but because
of the fragility of their finite psyches
if whatever forces that created the back
rooms did intended to be a realm that
tormented humans the humans were
definitely making it too easy and if
humans themselves made this to contain
other humans the implications were even
sillier when the very structures that
humans built to shelter themselves from
the elements apartment buildings cities
towns were able to cause this much fear
in them it was a sure sign that Humanity
was always doomed to retreat screaming
back into the Wilderness after centuries
of learning nothing from its Collective
delusion of civilization or at least
they would be doomed to that fate if
they weren't already doomed to be wiped
out by a cp682 just like every entity in
the back rooms 682 wouldn't rest until
every last faceling Clump death moth
death rat Smiler Hound dollar burster
and any other ridiculous entity that
dared to crawl through these wretched
corridors was personally sent to its end
it got so pumped up thinking about this
that it didn't even notice itself no
clipping again thousands of floors
rushed by in the blink of a moment until
the reptile finally dropped through the
lobby of the apartment building a new
level unlocked just like that
scp-682 regained its bearings on a
forest floor covered in a vibrant
Crimson grass the trees had pitched
black bark almost blending in with the
Knight itself the sky above was a
glistening sea of Bright Stars this was
level 14 known to most explorers as
Paradise this level had a strange power
which supposedly made the Explorer happy
and feeling as though they belonged
however much like the darkness within
the suburbs level 14's
happiness-inducing atmosphere would have
the opposite effect on the hard to
destroy reptile it hated this Forest
even more than any previous level of the
back rooms and wanted out immediately
from experience 682 knew that poking
around would eventually result in it
finding the entrance to the next level
so it hightailed its way through the
trees it needed to find that exit
desperately as it ran through the woods
682 could hear howlings somewhere far in
the distance and it didn't sound like a
pack of wild animals disturbingly it
sounded like a crowd of humans
attempting noises similar to wolves but
they were committing so much to the
performance that it almost seemed like
they truly believed they were wolves
whatever hippie-dippy nonsense was going
on here wasn't
scp-682's concern right now it was
burning with so much contempt for level
14 that I could barely think straight
its feet crashed through a field of pale
white bones lying just beneath the grass
but it kept on running they collided
with a tree Downing it in a second but
it just kept running
the howling ceased in the distance and
still scp-682 continued to run as fast
and as far as it could then Against All
Odds the creature's own mind began to
turn against it as the effect of level
14 continued to take hold you don't
belong anywhere you are a mistake of
nature
scp-682 could recognize its own voice
echoing in its head and for the first
time it was terrified of itself you are
a thing that cannot ever be happy this
paradise will never accept you nowhere
will ever accept you you are disgusting
scp-682 froze in its tracks there was no
exit from this place the back rooms had
won the sick game it was playing with
the reptile's existence it would be
trapped here forever in this inverted
Paradise for humans a self-loathing
Immortal without any hope of Escape it
was so paralyzed by the immense disgust
that it felt for itself that it almost
didn't notice a speck of blue amongst
all the red the blue on the feathers of
a hyacinth macaw Jerry
scp-682 said aloud don't follow him you
are a monster you will never know
companionship or love shut up you
disgusting creature
scp-682 growled back at its own mind
shakely it began to move its legs in the
direction of Jerry The bird-like Entity
was the only thing that still felt real
about level 14. everything practically
faded away into a churning ocean of red
and black it took every ounce of
willpower that SCP 682 had but it kept
moving towards Jerry you are the most
disgusting monster to ever exist the
foundation should have destroyed you the
back rooms will destroy you you don't
belong in this world
scp-682 did everything it could to shut
out the voice even as Jerry took off and
flew deeper into the Crimson forests of
level 14. without even realizing 682 had
grown a pair of blue wings of its own it
followed Jerry through the trees and
then higher toward the Starry Sky one
thought cut all the negativity that had
been swirling through as
cp-682's mind it doesn't matter if I
don't belong anywhere else Jerry is all
I need a light Shone down from above and
suddenly it was as if level 14 itself
was rejecting
scp-682 while the reptile was focused on
Jerry a piece of the sky seemed to
glitch and then as if it were a solid
piece of Machinery it fell down toward
the red grass below behind the Fallen
chunk of sky was a metallic hallway not
unlike some of those back at the
foundation Jerry flew through the
opening and scp-682 followed with its
own macaw-like feathered wings a shift
in gravity much like the event on level
7 occurred and 682 soon found itself
standing inside of a long silvery
Corridor having come through a hole in
the ceiling goodbye level 14 hello level
15 the futuristic hallways oh yeah the
future rules here we are in the future
and it's right it was certainly a lot
less of a personal nightmare to scp-682
Jerry had clearly flown ahead but 682
knew somewhere deep down that it
wouldn't have made it here without him
if the reptile had any respect for the
concept of fairness it'd probably
considered the debt for Jerry fleeing in
level 10 to be repaid but its empathy
wasn't quite so sophisticated that it
could wave favors like that so it's
soldiered on looking to catch up with
Jerry for no particular reason at least
as far as it knew the hallways were
definitely man-made in appearance but
from a time so technologically advanced
that even the found
couldn't dream of it the best part about
level 15 was that it was filled with
what appeared to be human remains most
of these corpses were marked with knife
and gunshot wounds perhaps the result of
some kind of Mass Slaughter either way
it was clear that all these humans had
been dead for a long time the only good
human is a dead human
scp-682 mused to itself it seemed that
the future did in fact kind of rule
because From scp-682's perspective level
15 was populated entirely by quote good
humans there was still no sign of Jerry
but there were also no annoying entities
to waste the reptile's time compared to
level 14 the futuristic hallways were
the real Paradise while it was as far
away as ever from feeling any kind of
authentic contentment
scp-682 decided that this place was
acceptable no life no Foundation I'm
starting to like it here
the eight long pointed legs of a massive
spider fangs dripping with deadly venom
skitter across the ground it is one of
the apex predators here until it's
crushed by the scaly foot of scp-682 the
back room's newest angriest resident
when we last left our least favorite
anomalous reptile
scp-682 was eight levels deep into the
terrifying extra-dimensional Labyrinth
known as the back rooms with scp-343
knows how many levels left to Traverse
the hard to destroy reptile was
beginning to feel a bubbling sense of
contempt for everything in this
god-forsaken reality that is to say
scp-682 felt this way it usually felt
but for once there was no feeble
Foundation Personnel to unleash its rage
on and while its long absence back in
the world outside of the back rooms has
been seen as a stressful inconvenience
for most of the foundation the fact that
the ketter class creature had done no
further harm since it evaded containment
had led many researchers to believe that
however unlikely it was
scp-682 no longer existed it's out of
our hair said one Dr Wazowski though the
foundation would continue to launch
around-the-clock reconnaissance missions
the world over the mobile task force
that seemingly did the deed of
destroying the hard to destroy reptile
was currently being treated to a company
pizza party paid for by the foundation's
Saria lizard ate your loved one fund
which received a small donation from the
o5 council every time that scp-682
breached containment but there was no
chance of relief for scp-682 itself as
wandering through the back rooms without
a map or strong sense of purpose was
certainly no pizza party level 8 the
level that scp-682 currently found
itself on was a Cave System crawling
with all manner of hostile entities well
hostile for a weak and pathetic human
beings at least to say the same was true
for scp-682 would be a gross Distortion
of the definition of the word hostile
especially because scp-682 had faced
many of these miserable monstrosities
before on the previous levels the clumps
hounds death rats and smilers were back
in droves and these now all two familiar
entities seemingly couldn't help
themselves from aggressively pouncing on
scp-682 the second that the reptile
entered their line of sight not that
getting the drop on the anomaly would
buy them any advantage as scp-682
effortlessly bodied them one after
another playing the hits already back
rooms as cp682 thought to itself at
least give me something new to chew on
through the jumbo of stalactites and
stalagmites scp-682 could see a child
faceling standing on the other side of
an unusual pit of tar the last time that
scp-682 encountered a few of these
unfittingly named faceless little girls
during its time on level 2 it had
ignored the entities out of a sense that
there would be more interesting monster
to destroy going forward
scp-682 now realized almost shamefully
that it had largely been proven wrong
perhaps the child facelings were in fact
more than meets the eye or knew
something that the other entities didn't
regardless there were never enough
pathetic cretans in the back rooms for
scp-682 to vent its nine Limitless
frustration on the small faceling would
simply be the next to bite the dust or
so
scp-682 thought as the hard to destroy
reptile charge towards the entity its
cause touched down on the puddle of tar
and almost immediately a countless
number of human hands emerge from the
liquid beneath and pulled 682 under the
anomaly was able to easily adapt the
level of strength necessary to escape
from the grasp of the tar pit entities
and resurface when it emerged however
the child face thing was nowhere to be
found
scp-682 had given the creepy little
Menace some credit as it was apparently
smarter than the other entity which had
crossed the lizard's path
scp-682 put as much distance between
itself and that an annoying tar pit as
it could and it was vigilant for any
other similar hazards not especially
amused by the concept of being swallowed
up again
scp-682 adapted a pair of large draconic
Wings which it used to carry itself
Aloft through the caves of level 8. from
above the anomaly could see a number of
foot-long centipede-like entities as
well as entities that resembled eyeless
chickens and for once neither of these
horrendous mistakes of creation seemed
interested in assaulting
scp-682 it was surprising but scp-682
actually felt a little bit relieved not
because it felt remotely threatened by
anything that crawled trotted or slung
through the back rooms but because it
didn't have to waste any of its valuable
time putting down another weakling that
should know better this relief was
short-lived as all of a sudden a large
shape dropped down on scp-682 from the
ceiling this monstrous human Lloyd
boasted four powerful Limbs and was
currently using all of them in an
attempt to Pummel scp-682 back down to
the ground 682 could see several similar
entities emerging from nearby Cavern
walls having apparently Blended in
through color changing camouflage and
lying completely still and wait for prey
or in the case of scp-682 the anomalous
lizard that would prey on them these
entities are called camel crawlers by
the major Explorer group and because
they have the same level of intelligence
as regular humans and cooperate to hunt
in packs they are regarded as one of the
most difficult entities to deal with not
for scp-682 of course and the hateful
bees could not be more disappointed in
this latest ill-conceived Ambush
scp-682 came to a landing on part of the
cavern floor which was decidedly not
covered with tar and allowed its wings
to attract back to its body without a
moment to spare it quickly made short
work of the camo crawlers a lot of them
may have been as smart as humans but
scp-682 had killed a lot of humans in
its time and an extra pair of arms
wasn't exactly a game changer now
surrounded by a record number of expired
back rooms entities scps 682 realized it
was growing sick of level 8. it seemed
that there was no winning with this
place as the levels that scp-682 had
visited previously either contain hordes
of worthless Expendable fodder like this
one or were so empty that the SCP would
find itself longing for any kind of
interaction it was time to search for an
exit to this level with the hope that
the next inconceivably vast Maze of
nothingness had a more refreshing flavor
to it knowing the back rooms the exit to
level 8 would probably come in the form
of an off-color portion of the cave wall
or some glitch geometry straight out of
those video games that younger humans
seem to love to play fortunately
scp-682 didn't have to think too hard
about how to progress to the next level
as after wandering around for long
enough it merely fell straight through a
random section of the floor Into
Darkness seconds later
scp-682 appeared in the Lamppost lit
streets of level 9. also known as the
infinite suburb it looked close to
midnight and much like in Michael
Jackson's hit song Thriller evil things
were no doubt lurking in the dark but
none more evil than the hard to destroy
reptile itself if level 9 was anything
like the suburbs that scp-682 remembered
from its native reality this place
should be filled with humans packed
together like sardines in a can and
while the lucky Foundation mobile task
force that was present at the site
scp-682 had no clipped into the back
rooms at were likely enjoying some
sardine pizza for a job well done
scp-682 was fixing to make the next
humans it encountered into its own kind
of unconventional topping for a feast it
was feeling oddly rejuvenated and almost
happy again but what it didn't know was
that the darkness of level 9 had the
same anomalous or I suppose vaguely
Supernatural properties of level six and
as the research suggests many kinds of
emotional inversion fields that unnerve
and disturb ordinary humans make scp-682
feel the opposite way it was strange but
somehow scp-682 felt almost like it
belonged here in Suburbia just a little
old me in a big big world
scp-682 moves to itself before trotting
down the pavement through the
neighborhood its mouth was starting to
water as it carefully deliberated over
which of these sleepy community homes it
would enter first the idea that behind
every door there were unsuspecting
humans fresh for the slaughter made this
place seem like a paradise for the
reptile this rare good mood even
remained as a new group of quote-unquote
hostile entities made their way down the
street towards SCP 682 alright then
let's meet the welcoming committee these
entities were known as the neighborhood
watch and the most relatively
interesting thing about their appearance
was that their Anatomy seemed to be
centered around singularly massive
eyeballs without hesitation one of these
cyclopean entities a floating eyeball
known as Watcher fired a piercing ray of
light at scp-682 which instantly
disintegrated portions of the reptile's
body on contact unlike the corrosive
acid used by the death moss and the oh
bursters from Level 5 God the damage
inflicted on scp-682 was at the atomic
level what this effectively meant is
that the Regeneration time to recover
from these injuries was going to be
slightly longer than usual the other
advantage that the Watchers had was
strength in numbers as there were three
of them as well as a pair of Striders
ambulatory eyeballs on eight foot legs
which brought up the rear of the
neighborhood watch 2 who can play at
that game said scp-682 it instantly
copied the Watcher's disintegration Rays
firing a pair of atomic lasers from both
eyes that would make a superhuman blush
these lasers of heat and light hit their
marks with perfect accuracy and
dismantled particles of the entire
approaching neighborhood watch as per
usual the back rooms then proceeded to
roll out the usual clown car of Stooges
scp-682 could see death moths a couple
skin Stealers and some particularly
wretched wretches hiding amongst the
suburban homes the reptile made a sport
of using its newly adapted laser vision
to pick them off one by one zap I see
you zap before long there were no more
backrooms entities in sight and scp-682
decided that it was time to break into
one of the homes on the street and go to
town or technically go to Suburbia honey
I'm home
scp-682 thought to itself as it smashed
through the front door of one of the
buildings inside was no trace of
habitation no food no photographs and
absolutely no humans oh well thought 682
still mellowed out from the effects of
the darkness there's always next door it
exited through the hole in the wallet
made and Strode across the lawn to the
next Little House on the Square knock
knock
scp-682 burst in once more and found
this house to be much the same state as
the last undaunted and feeling
persistent
scp-682 made its way down the street
like a terrifying door-to-door salesman
bursting through the front door of every
house in its path telegram special
delivery I'm here to talk to you about
your car's Insurance there was nothing
no humans anywhere level 9 seemed to be
one big empty Ghost Town
scp-682 started to consider the
implications of the number of entities
it had encountered earlier while they
were little more than distractions for
682 the chances were very slim that any
humans that had made it this far could
have survived such a plethora of Dime
Store goofballs
scp-682 let out an uncharacteristically
wistful sigh the backgrounds have me all
messed up I can't believe I'm actually
missing those disgusting humans I've
grown accustomed to their faces
scp-682 reflected on this for a moment
and then had another realization no this
is perfect I'm free I may never see
these worthless creatures again they'll
never inflict their pathetic existence
on what is mine I am free
scp-682 howled in private triumphant
Victory as it rambled through the
streets of this dead World unknown to
humans and especially unknown to the
foundation this was nothing like the
endless office spaces of level 4 because
the darkness negated any possible
depression that scp-682 could develop as
a result of being deprived of other
entities to interact with even then it
was clear that there would be more than
enough entities for scp-682 to destroy
if it got bored while there was no
telling how often entities in the back
room spawn or where they really come
from there never seemed to be a shortage
in the levels where they did exist
scp-682 began to think that level 9 was
in fact the paradise it appeared to be
at first glance Against All Odds
scp-682 had achieved genuine Bliss and
it seemed that nothing could take that
away as scp-682 stood there staring up
into the starless black void of level 9
Sky it was caught off guard by the
sudden presence of what appeared to be a
blue Hyacinth Macaw landing on its back
the bird had given no indication that it
was nearby and because of that it had
somehow taken scp-682 completely by
surprise what's more the reptile was
feeling an unusual sensation Within mind
it knew almost instinctively that this
avian entity's name was Jerry and also
it was one of the only beings 682 had
ever encountered that it didn't outright
want to destroy it wasn't that scp-682
like Jerry or even really cared for if
he lived or died there was something
about this unusual Macabre that didn't
trigger the usual disgust response that
every other form of life brought out in
682 this was an admiration or friendship
but more like optimistic indifference
Your Existence is acceptable Jerry said
682 to its Newfound winged companion
let's go find some weaklings to kill
weaklings Jerry replied and so 682 was
off again this time with Jerry and tow
it was like the two of them against the
world and together they could take on
anything
scp-682 and Jerry out on adventures
running around and accomplishing great
things in the back rooms 100 Years of
scp-682 and Jerry eventually the asphalt
and suburban houses gave way to an
unpaved dirt path leading through a
field of wheat within moments the
darkness was replaced with a dense fog
and the black of the night sky changed
into the gray of a cloudy afternoon
scp-682 breathed in the moist air and
realized once again it had moved between
levels of the back rooms without knowing
it this was Level 10 the infinite wheat
field at this point the word infinite
was starting to feel cheap some warning
would have been nice as cp682 grumbled
no longer feeling as Serene without the
benefits of level 9's Darkness at least
Jerry was still here there was a silver
lining to everything no
scp-682 stomped its feet on the ground
in building frustration it needed to
find something to tear to Pieces
immediately or might reconsider even its
tolerance to Jerry the Macaw was now its
last resort in case there was no other
entities on this level fortunately for
Jerry
scp-682 became alerted by the echoing
sounds of trumpets coming from further
into the wheat field and decided to
investigate Through The Mists of level
scp-682 could see the Silhouettes of
several large Stone Towers
scp-682 didn't recognize the exact time
period of the architecture the way a
human might assume they were from the
Middle Ages but it could definitely tell
that these were old it hadn't destroyed
something like this in ages and it
seemed as though it would soon be given
a reason to perched high on the towers
were a small Patrol of goblinoid
creatures wielding bows and arrows these
entities spotted scp-682 around the same
time it spotted them and began to knock
arrows from their Quivers and opened
fire relentlessly on the reptile these
ancient projectiles stung but compared
to the disintegration Rays from the
Watchers
scp-682 saw this as a bit of a downgrade
the only real harm that it did to
scp-682 was spiritual as the reign of
arrows seemed to startle Jerry and cause
the Macaw to take flight away from
scp-682 Jerry get back here you coward
scp-682 shouted to The bird-like Entity
as it disappeared from sight it shook
its head however brief it was it seemed
that the scp-682 and Jerry team up had
come to an end stupid bird he better
hope I don't see him again The Archers
continue to Pepper scp-682 with arrows
but the reptile wasn't about to take
medieval warfare lying down with extreme
speed scp-682 charged at the nearest
Tower and rammed it head on the impact
shook the structure causing the archers
to stumble and drop some of their arrows
despite the damage the tower hadn't
fully crumbled so as cp682 underwent a
brand new adaptation to settle the score
armored plates converged at the end of
scp-682's tail forming a large
bludgeoning Club similar to that of an
Ankylosaurus with a power and speed of
682's body behind it this bony Mass was
more accurately described as a wrecking
ball and it came in like a wrecking ball
too as the reptile swung its whole body
with enough Force to smash the base of
the tower into pieces as the stone fell
so did The Archers and many were buried
beneath the rubble While others
scattered retreating to farther Towers
while taking pot shots at 682 the
reptile didn't chase them it had bigger
plans it waited until the archers had
made their way into the next few Towers
before grabbing a piece of rubble in its
mouth and chucking it directly up into
the air the chunk of stone flew upwards
and then began to descend rapidly
towards the wheat field below
demonstrating an eye for precision on
par with the siege Engineers of medieval
times
scp-682 swung its club tail at the
perfect moment to hit the falling Stone
and change its course it was a home run
scp-682 scored a direct hit on the top
of the next Tower and repeated its Stone
chucking strategy until the archers
began to get the message this was a war
the likes of which these Freddie freaker
looking demons had never experienced the
hard to destroy reptile roared a
blustering Battle Cry and began to
berate the entities for their weakness
you miscreants deserve this for scaring
Jerry away
scp-682 said without really thinking
what had gotten into it some strange
anomalous effect it pondered this as it
continued to perform its rather
convincing impression of a catapult The
Archers had completely taken cover at
this point afraid to retaliate for fear
of getting a rock to the face not long
after the same trumpet noise could be
heard again and the area around the
towers became a lot less active it did
take scp-682 a moment or two to realize
that the entities had all disappeared
with the sound of that instrument
cowards would be cowards after all the
reptile was aching for more of a fight
but at the very least level 10 was
offering something new though not all of
it was new a Smiler peeked out at
scp-682 from between stalks of Wheat and
this time the reptiles simply chose to
ignore The Uncanny grinning bastard and
move on no sense giving it the
satisfaction right
scp-682 followed the dirt path for about
a day during which time it also
encountered a pack of hounds a skin
stealer and who could say how many death
rats that scampered admits the field
after this it came to what appeared to
be some kind of settlement the buildings
here looked much more modern than the
towers and unlike the empty suburbs of
level 9 the reptile could see that there
were actual humans living here from all
appearances this appeared to be a small
town square with an open-air Trading
Post much like a farmer's market in
addition to wheat the humans living in
this settlement had all sorts of goods
on display and could be seen actively
bartering with each other
scp-682 licked its lips none of these
helpless fools knew it was coming malt
town as it was known to wander as in the
back rooms was about to receive a rude
awakening at the hands of a ketter class
SCP while The Archers that have been
encountered earlier posed a definite
threat to those straying too close to
their towers the entities seemed to
conveniently ignore this humble little
town of course Mercy was not in
scp-682's Playbook except when it came
to Jerry apparently but the Macaw was
gone now and it was time for Carnage
this was going to be fun welcome back to
the show we once again joined scp-682
and its trusty macaw sidekick Jerry deep
in the depths of the liminal Abyss known
as the back rooms the hard to destroy
reptile had been seemingly contained
within the back rooms for such a lengthy
period of time that it was likely even
the SCP Foundation had given up on
searching for it after unintentionally
no clipping out of reality 682 was
apparently doomed to wander these
endless Labyrinthian realities until the
end of its miserable existence the
latest level it had arrived in appeared
to take the form of a vast desert
stretching from Horizon to Horizon
sandstorms buffeted the creature and
Powerful gusts of wind forced Jerry to
take refuge clinging tightly to its much
larger friends back this was level 16
but there was far more to it than first
met the eye as the lizard and bird made
their way across the Titanic Dunes
strange lights began to Circle in the
air above these were entities known as
light Guides singularities of pale light
that bore a strong resemblance to Willow
the Wisp ghostly fire Elementals out of
folklore much like the mysterious wisps
of Legend light guides appear to
Travelers in the back rooms Whenever
there is an impending danger you'd think
with all the malicious entities and
bizarre has hazards that scp-682 had
encountered in the previous levels it
would have seen a lot more of these but
considering how dangerous 682 itself was
the light guides probably had their
non-existent hands full keeping other
Travelers away from it either way their
numbers and proximity meant that
whatever was about to happen was going
to be something perilous Jerry squawked
and nibbled at scp-682 with his beak
trying to warn the reptile of the danger
682 had no idea what to expect but made
sure to have its guard up and keep its
avian companion close the creature's
instincts were sharp as ever and the
second that the level began to rearrange
itself 682 was already taking evasive
action the sand hardened and turned to
stone as great pyroclastic flows began
to erupt from what were once the dunes
682 leaped across a deep fissure just as
it opened up beneath the lizard's feet
narrowly avoiding a several hundred foot
drop into a lake of LA lava Ash rain
from the sky as all traces of the desert
were completely overwritten into this
new volcanic landscape this was the
defining Supernatural feature of level
16. an environment that randomly
reshaped itself into different
geographical climates and terrains now
that it had seen the level change
completely once
scp-682 was already over the concept
rather than stick around and take a bath
in the lava
scp-682 decided to follow the light
guides towards what appeared to be a
portal made out of concentrated blue
light it passed through the portal and
found itself in a cramped hallway
resembling those aboard a nautical
vessel out with level 16 and in with
level 17. otherwise known as the naval
aircraft carrier though there was no
actual deck of the proverbial carrier
nor any potential aircrafts in the back
rooms for it to transport there didn't
seem to be much happening on level 17 at
least in comparison to the draft terrain
shifting of level 16. there were also
absolutely no entities to be seen as far
as 682 could tell of course level 17 was
faxing to the reptile in a different way
the corridor it found itself in was such
an extremely tight fit moving freely was
next to Impossible the back rooms was
once again telegraphing the fact that it
was made with humans and not overgrown
lizards in mind waste of effort 682
thought to itself not even the most
disgusting human had enough dumb luck to
make it this far after a few minutes of
struggle 682 shrunk down to a more
manageable size so it could Traverse the
hallways it was now roughly the size of
a male hyacinth macaw that is to say
jerry-sized and it crawled through the
narrow corridors of level 17 with room
to spare there was still no sign of
hostile entities and given the
propensity for clumps to come
avalanching out of the woodwork on
previous levels 682 saw saw this as a
mercy it was also grateful to no longer
be exposed to the elements on level 16.
scp-682 passed the time exploring this
seemingly empty corridors by having
one-sided small talk with Jerry the
Macaw couldn't do much more than chirp
and squawk back and before too long 682
realized that it had very little to talk
about its main interests were
slaughtering living things and breaching
containment and both of these topics
were irreverent to the current mood a
wave of embarrassment washed over the
creature as for the first time it had
genuine concern that a social
interaction could go poorly it didn't
want to frighten Jerry away or come
across as awkward it was just that
conversation with like-minded anomalies
had been far easier at the foundation
since the shared experience of being
contained was always a good starting
point the reptile also had fond memories
of the time it got to chat with
scp-079 an old AI that the foundation
secured around the same time time as
itself though it was an unusual feeling
for a creature so filled with contempt
and hatred
scp-682 had started to realize that it
wanted to build the same kind of rapport
with Jerry maybe getting lost in the
back rooms was exactly the kind of life
experience it needed to become more
approachable to the few beings it could
respect that being said the current
level it was on was rather underwhelming
as a way of making memories just then
scp-682 saw what appeared to be an
ordinary human up ahead it had its back
turn to the reptile and Jerry and seemed
to be unaware of their presence a
sitting dock oh good a distraction
thought the flustered lizard I was
totally sounding like I had no life
scp-682 charged toward the human as fast
as its shrunken body could carry it
Jerry followed suit flapping his wings
and flying alongside 682 as the duo
approached the human began to turn
around what 682 anticipated was a look
of abject horror on the human's face but
instead The Entity simply stared through
682 as if the reptile wasn't even there
682 was confused but even stranger was
the fact that its Consciousness was
starting to fade 682 blinked and in what
felt like a second later it awoke at
full size half wedged in an aircraft
carrier doorway Jerry was squawking up a
storm and that was presumably what had
woken 682 back up it also seemed that
making eye contact with that humanoid
entity had somehow caused 682 to faint
temporarily The Entity itself was long
gone much to 682's Chagrin this
phenomenon was easy enough for any
expert in backroom's lore to explain as
level 17 was home to Unique entities
known as imprints which resembled humans
but had the supernatural ability to
induce brain death in anything that
looked them in the eyes even so this was
an unacceptable outcome to
scp-682 had the entities been growing
stronger as the level number went higher
or was the reptile simply losing its
mental fortitude maybe all the strange
properties of this place were
compounding on the creature and slowly
making it go soft 682 shrunk down again
and shook off the shame of its encounter
with the imprint the only way to prove
that it was better than the back rooms
was by advancing through all the levels
and taking down whatever entities stood
in its way this would probably mean
facing at least one more pompous jerk
with a spear like tiny and Argos before
and 682 relished the chance to Triumph
in another bout of single combat besides
if another fair fight like those were to
take place 682 would be able to show off
how strong it was to Jerry that alone
was reason enough to find the entrance
to the next level the time for brooding
was over it was now time for action and
adventure even if it took 100 years 682
would not rest until it made it through
every level of the back rooms and left
the entire hellish Dimension devoid of
the life it's so despised it wandered
the hallways of level 17 until it found
a door that was discolored compared to
the other ones almost as if there was a
photo negative Spotlight shining on it
from the other side it was about to pass
through when the same imprint it had
encountered earlier stepped into the
hallway
fool me once 682 growled and confidently
initiated a staring contest with the
creature that feeling of losing
Consciousness was felt immediately but
this time 682 suppressed it through
sheer well with all of its vast brain
power it fought to stay awake and even
began to concentrate the distressing
emotions into its gaze the imprints
stood and continued to look at 682 but
within mere moments The Entity was
frothing at the mouth and falling
backwards against the wall as the
effects of its own stair were reflected
back at it through a mirror 682 may have
been caught off guard the first time but
its signature adaptation abilities meant
that there was never a second time exit
stage right the reptile opened the door
to the next level and moved on to level
18 which was known as the level of
memories level 18 was said to take on a
subjective appearance that was different
to every individual Wanderer but would
usually resemble a place from childhood
this was no different for 682 and the
hard to destroy reptile was shocked to
find itself in the very same primeval
Forest where it and its countless
siblings first went to war against
ancient humankind there were even
corpses littered around like in the
futuristic hallways of level 15 only
these dead creatures were far more
familiar to the reptile the vast
majority were human Warriors in Bronze
Age armor still gripping Antiquated
weapons such as swords and axes among
these Fallen humans were the occasional
dead giant beasts though these bodies
were rather few in number as casualty
use on the scp-682 side of this war had
been almost non-existent 682 had never
thought it would see this place or those
of its kind that were too weak to
survive the battlefield again it was a
strange and uncomfortable feeling not
helped by the raspy Whispering voices
that seemed to linger in the Wind of
level 18. your father will never look
for you for he has already transcended
that momentary flash of anger that
brought you and the rest of your litter
into being he only has further use for
your mother his bride she is worth a
million of you no matter how many
battles you fought in the name of his
hate despite the ghoulish intensity of
the whispering voices the words they
said were clear and direct impossible to
mistake but the part that really caused
scp-682's blood to boil was the fact
that these voices seem to know more more
about its past than even the foundation
did tell me disgraced Prince of Wrath
what hurts more the fact that you proved
weak enough to fall into the clutches of
your greatest enemies or the fact that
those same lab coats and soldiers were
the first ones that allowed you an
identity of your own distinct from the
whims of your pathetic father lost in
the wicked siren song of level 18's
voices 682 suddenly noticed that Jerry
had flown off again or perhaps he had
never entered level 18 with the reptile
at all he'd call down for the Macaw but
there was no answer 682 found all of
this to be very distressing especially
since these Whispers seem to come from
some powerful unseen force that knew
exactly what the reptile viewed as its
greatest failures it was different from
the influx of negative thoughts that
level 14 caused since then that had been
a product of 682's own mind what was
happening here on level 18 was different
a separate malevolent Consciousness
perhaps the creator of the back rooms
itself was completely aware of all of
682's childhood trauma and was
deliberately using it against the
creature physical threats were one thing
that 682 had always been able to
overcome but a psychological attack of
this degree was beyond the capabilities
of even the foundation still there had
to be a way out of level 18 or at least
a way back to Jerry either would have
given 682 a bit of breathing room from
the influence of The Whispers
fortunately things weren't quite as dire
as they seemed as scp-682 was about to
be reminded that not all the entities in
the back rooms meant to do harm enter
entity 198 nicknamed the plush dino by
the explorer who first discovered it
while level 18 is not the only level of
the back rooms it can appear on the
plush die often patrols the reality of
childhood memories in search of
Wanderers in distress and in the
compromised psychological state it was
in right now
scp-682 surprisingly fit that
description thus prompting entity 198 to
come to its Aid at first
scp-682 didn't know what to make of this
peculiar synthetic looking entity it
approached with no ill well and
wordlessly attempted to comfort the
reptile through gentle contact
scp-682 swiped at the creature with its
claw as always it was not in the mood
for cuddling with a stuffed toy entity
198 seemed to be able to dodge the
reptile's attacks easily and continue to
do so as 682 made repeated attempts to
destroy it nothing connected and the
plush Dino circled the hard to destroy
reptile without a scratch what do you
want from me you worthless little creep
682 screamed at the dyno at which point
The Entity turned and started to speed
away in a random Direction 682 gave
Chase suing entity 198 through its own
childhood memories towards what appeared
to be the door that had led it into
level 18 to begin with the blush Dino
opened the door and proceeded to walk
the dinosaur into the door without even
considering whether doing so would send
itself back to level 17
scp-682 followed the plush Dino and
instead found itself in the back rooms
level 19. the attic turns out that being
blinded by anchor always helps one get
further in life that's a positive lesson
with no unfortunate implications Jerry
had already arrived in level 19 prior to
682 so chasing the plush Dino was even
more of a smart decision than the
reptile could have imagined Jerry 682
said running up to the Macaw and wagging
its tail Jerry fluttered down from the
attic Rafters and landed on 682's snout
682 a high he squawked having remembered
682's designation number apparently he
had been paying attention to the
conversation earlier this means that 682
had confirmation that it hadn't totally
screwed up this new friendship yet on
top of that it was nice to know that
Jerry had no intention of abandoning the
reptile this was certainly a warm and
touching reunion though the continued
presence of the smugly grinning plush
Dino almost ruined it 682 snapped its
head towards the offending entity and
barked an insult at it hoping that it
would get the message and leave but
entity 198 did No Such Thing preferring
to silently watch the wholesome
interaction between 682 and Jerry from a
safe distance whatever 682 thought it
wasn't going to waste any more time on
the impish little stuffed animal that's
when Jerry swooped down and landed next
to the plush Dino 198 Jerry squawked he
then waddled across the wooden attic
floorboards in between 682 and 198 and
swapped again it was as if he was trying
to introduce the two and this mortified
682 was this thing a friend of Jerry's
and if so did that mean he was going to
have to co-exist with it at the very
least the plush Dino didn't seem to be
alive in the conventional sense but
whether that meant it was an animated
object or some kind of machine remained
as vague and mysterious as most things
in the back rooms even though it didn't
technically fall into the very broad
category of living organism that 682
wanted to wipe out that didn't
automatically disqualify the miniature
monster as being disgusting especially
if the dinosaur was getting overly
friendly with Jerry the blue Hyacinth
Macaw belonged to 682 and it didn't feel
like sharing especially not with some
clingy toy after the awkward
introductions were over 682 and its two
tagalong companions had a look at level
19. it definitely resembled the attic of
a household complete with Dusty
discarded furniture and several boxes of
photo albums and other mementos there
was also the orange glow and unusual
fiery light that laminated from beneath
the floorboards
scp-682 didn't know why but the glow
reminded it of the same memories that it
just had to relive on the previous level
this time though 682 was drawn to
thinking about the more positive aspects
of its proverbial childhood if one could
call crushing human skulls beneath its
claws and facing down entire armies of
humans to be positives the truth was
that scp-682 was being mildly affected
by the orange glow of level 19 which had
the memetic ability to insinuate its way
into the former memories of anyone who
wandered through the level but 682 had
spent enough time having its childhood
ruined today and decided to search for
the exit after all if there were no
entities present on this floor it would
be a waste of time to stick around and
play into the hands of whatever was
making that orange glow thankfully it
seemed that the entity 198 was already
one step ahead of 682 in the hunt for an
exit the plush Dyno had located a
severely damaged wooden door with the
number 20 painted in orange on its
surface no doubt this was the entrance
to the next level
scp-682 was still very annoyed that the
plush Dino had insisted on hanging
around but if it was going to actually
be useful the reptile would be sure to
make the most of it 682 Jerry and the
dino entered the broken doorway and
found themselves inside of a wide open
Warehouse room there were several
corridors leading out of the room that
appeared to be filled with crates on
wooden and plastic pallets this was
level 20 the warehouse although it
resembled many earlier floors of the
back rooms it was surprisingly finite
both the corridors and the room were not
of an unusual size compared to their
equivalence in the real world and
according to explorers the warehouse
itself was only about 300 kilometers
wide at the most though stats weren't
especially impressive if you asked
scp-682 whatever happened to the
infinite labyrinths of liminal spaces
scp-682 wondered ever since the city
level it's been nothing but confined
spaces weird mind screw ones and that
landscape that kept changing for no
reason what happened to the classic back
rooms
scp-682 quickly came to its senses and
realized what it was thinking classic
back rooms it sounded like one of those
snobby Foundation researchers deciding
what was a genuine SCP and what wasn't
based on some incredibly arbitrary
standard besides there were no levels of
the back rooms that were remotely
acceptable for 682 other than maybe
level 9 and breaking them down into
further categories went against the
reptile's ultimate goal of destroying
this horrendous place and everything
associated with it it wouldn't become
like the foundation it hated by being
specific and thorough broad sweeping
statements were more scp-682 style and
when it came to the back rooms every
level was equally disgusting 682 turned
to its Companions and growled with what
seemed to be excitement Jerry let's get
moving you two piece of garbage dinosaur
as a creature that had spent so much of
its existence in captivity surrounded by
beings it deemed disgusting
scp-682 was not used to having seemingly
unlimited freedom to explore and was
even less used to having tolerable
company and yet hear the hard to destroy
reptile was entering into level 21 of
the back rooms with not one but two
accidental companions the back rooms
were bad enough when faced alone and the
addition of annoying Hangers On only
made the whole experience that much more
unbearable for 682 even the fact that
scp-682 was free of the foundation was
little consolation when being contained
in the back rooms was proving to be a
far more terrible fate than a lifetime
spent in a vat of acid the first and
most important was that the infinitely
lovable and perfectly blue hyacinth
called Jerry who scp-682 had known for
only 12 levels of the back rooms but
would undoubtedly kill everything in
sight if anything happened to him of
course the lizard tended to want to do
that anyway but the sentiment was strong
nonetheless 682 felt the complete
opposite way about the plush Dino back
room's entity 198 that had been tagging
along ever since level 18. there was
something about its dumb little smiling
face that filled 682 with a boiling rage
not to mention the fact that having the
animated toy around would mean that
Jerry's much desired attention would be
split between it and 682 three was most
certainly a crown and if the tiny legged
Scamp wasn't so proficient at dodging
682's unprovoked claw strikes and tail
slaps the hard to destroy reptile would
have cut the plush Dino out of the
equation but 682 would need to conserve
some energy for the entities that lurked
in the back rooms level
a series of four hallways Yes you heard
that right there were only four hallways
in level 21 not infinite hallways not a
Labyrinth of hallways not even the same
four hallways repeated in an endless
loop four hallways that's it as a
consequence of the much smaller scale of
level 21 the roving bands of entities
that normally are spread out across a
much larger Dimension find themselves
clustered together in the cramped linear
span of the four hallways even a medium
entity account can be impossibly
dangerous when an Explorer is faced with
the iconic backrooms monsters at once
well unless those entities are up
against
scp-682 go on make my day it roared the
approaching Regiment of death moths
death rats facelings hounds bursters
smilers clumps and even some completely
unknown weirdos marched like soldiers
specifically the gorgonites from from
the 1998 action comedy movie Small
Soldiers because these things were
equally messed up looking and equally
known for fighting losing battles
however scp-682 charged Into The Horde
it noticed that this time the entities
were a bit more tactical in the way they
approached combat was this also a unique
property of level 21 or was the back
rooms taking a page out of 682's book
and adapting to new threats the clumps
vaulted with their many hands and rolled
along the walls to get behind 682 while
the hounds and facelings made a frontal
assault the smilers soon joined the
clumps on the other side using their
uncanny ability to shift through the
Shadows the death rats nod at 682 from
underneath attacking the reptile's
footing and doing everything they could
to distract it all the while the death
moths and bursters acted as artillery
shooting acidic slime from a safe
distance behind the other entities or in
the case of the death moths from above
just Out Of 682's Reach
scp-682 almost had to applaud the
pathetic entities for getting their act
together it was facing a mobile task
force made up of rejected Dungeons and
Dragons monsters a valiant effort but
doomed to end in their defeat these
entities were not the foundation and
scp-682 refused to lose to a bunch of
aberrations cosplaying as a containment
Squad it was time to give them a taste
of their own medicine and during the
attacks of many entities at once
scp-682 became a chimera of monstrous
features stolen from various backrooms
entities the freakish grin of a Smiler
spread across its face while the
grasping arms of a clump emerge from its
back along with an impressive pair of
death moth Wings the ever disgusting
acid shooting pustules of a burster
appeared across 682's body pointing in
every direction like the Cannons on a
naval ship now fully off optimized to
take down the organized entities with
their own weapons
scp-682 roared out a Battle Cry death to
the back rules all burster ponds
ruptured at once forcing the entities to
take evasive action most did not get far
thanks to 682's countless Clump arms
which grappled and held on to everything
within reach as 682 pulled the entities
in towards its teeth and Claws the
shredding began their numbers were thin
quickly and the once organized Legion
fell in disarray with entities
indecisive lean making desperate attacks
or tactical Retreats now the resemblance
between this Skirmish with the entities
on level 21 and the ones that scp-682
had with mobile task forces back at the
foundation containment facility was
nearly perfect except this time no Force
military or otherwise would come along
to put 682 back into confinement now
this was freedom did you
did you Cherry that was classic 682 I
still got it the reptile boasted
Jerry replied in the excitement of
Victory
scp-682 almost forgot that entity 198
was still here watching the aftermath of
the Carnage with the same smile it
always wore nevertheless 682 felt rather
strongly that the plush Dino was judging
it nobody asked you plush Dino he
grumbled on some level the plush Dino
was most likely aware of
scp-682's overwhelming animosity but it
was also a simple entity driven by
appropriately simplistic desires it had
its own reasons for staying by the
reptile side in its usual role on level
18 the plush Diner would seek out
explorers lost in their own traumatic
memories and guide them towards safety
whatever safety meant in the back rooms
the adorable entity had an inherent
biological or Supernatural radar sense
that allowed it to detect individuals
experiencing distress and suffering
since the majority of backrooms explore
are human the margin of distress that
the plush Dino could detect and respond
to was kept within the relative limits
of normalcy for this reason the plush
Dino had never encountered any being
that carried more feelings of distress
than 682 the hard to destroy reptile was
from entity 198's perspective the most
mentally pained creature in existence
the plush Dino's top priority was now to
be a Beacon of Hope For What it saw as a
victim of the ultimate forms of
unaddressed trauma of course it was a
non-verbal entity and possessed no
telepathic or empathetic abilities so
conveying it's more wholesome
therapeutic intentions to scp-682 was
next to Impossible especially since a
being as aggressive and hateful as 682
would be wholly unreceptive to the
notion of hugging away its problems but
this would not stop entity 198 from
making the rehabilitation of its now
ketter class charge the meaning of its
oddly specific existence even if that
meant leaving potentially thousands of
tortured human explorers eternally Lost
In level 18. the plush Dino was now
embodying the I can fix him mentality to
its logical extreme after trying several
doors throughout level 21 it was clear
that the majority of them simply LED
back into other parts of level 21's four
hallways much like the doors in a chase
scene from a Hanna-Barbera cartoon
eventually 682 and his party members
stumbled Upon A dimensional tear in the
side of one of the hallways this looked
like the entrance to the next level so
682 decided to throw caution to the wind
and step through into level 22 the car
park which unlike some of the previous
levels was in fact infinite for whatever
that was worth a few damaged 50s era
automobiles occupied the parking spots
their metal rusted and torn to shreds
more curiously there was what appeared
to be a circus tent wedged between some
of the concrete supports there were no
entities around the main area of level
21. so scp-682 entered the tent thinking
that it was perhaps another exit for
once it seemed that the back rooms
weren't subverting the reptile's
expectations as inside the tent was none
other than the inside of a tent rows of
plastic folded chairs sat within facing
a wooden Podium on an elevated stage
this tent was made to hold many humans
but strangely there was only one an old
man in ragged hiking gear that stood
amongst the chairs scribbling notes into
a journal of sorts he wore an enormous
backpack that swelled with supplies and
unusual bottled items though the Fallen
Nation of unstable lived inside of tents
like this one the old man muttered to
himself he then looked over his shoulder
and noticed scp-682 glaring at him he
closed his journal and stared back with
an inquisitive look on his face
oh a new entity I don't get to see that
every day the human laughed though why
is it with entity 7 and entity 198 if
those numbers are so important to
mine is six eight two
scp-682 growled entity 682 as the old
man scratching his white beard how have
I never heard of you I am not an entity
scp-682 snapped back
the old man Shrugged and said I fail to
see the distinction that makes two of us
682 thought anyway anomaly 682 I'd
advise against attacking me I'm rather
busy collecting notes for the kalag
Institute and I can be a force of nature
when I'm interrupted I've dealt with
bigger and scarier things than you so
wander off and leave me to my work the
old man had far too much confidence for
682's liking who did this human think he
was anyway it was not going to be talked
down to like that especially not by
someone from any kind of Institute it
was go time without another word the
reptile began plowing through the chairs
towards the elderly human who in a
display of agility unexpected for
someone his age gracefully hopped across
the chairs to the stage successfully
evading 682's charge well I did warn you
the old man reached into his pack and
produced a small dark object carved of
lapis lazuli stone it resembled a Scarab
or dung beetle and there were
hieroglyphics across the base of it the
old man chanted a prayer to the stone
invoking the name of the Egyptian god
kepri and causing the scarab's wings to
extend a great blue light was emitted
from the lapis stone and a terrible
droning Buzz hit 682 all at once
stunning it for a moment the old man
left to the wing Beetle hovering in the
air and proceeded to draw two more
unusual objects from his knapsack in one
hand he held a bottle of fine red powder
while on the other held a bottle that
appeared to contain electrical energy he
hurled both at scp-682 and ducked for
over behind the stage upon impact the
bottles created a large explosion of
electrical Flames which immediately
caused the entire tent to go up the old
man drew a large knife and cut his way
out to the tent leaving 682 behind to
burn as the structure collapsed the
human made a break for the nearest
concrete ramp leading down to the lower
areas of the parking garage he looked
back to see a heavily scorched 682 in
Hot Pursuit but no signs of entity 7
Jerry and entity 198 the plush Dino The
Entity no the anomaly was more durable
than the old man expected and far more
willing to endure pain if it meant
chasing down prey in a desperate bid to
keep the monster from Catching him the
old man retrieved a crystal and metal
artifact from his inventory it was known
as a pocket and true to its name it
contained a pocket Dimension which could
store large objects and release them at
the command of its user earlier in his
trip through level 22 the old man had
stored a couple of damaged cars in the
pocket in case he needed to cover from
an attacking entity as 682 gained on him
he summoned the cars back from the
pocket causing them to land in the
reptile's path while ineffective at
stopping the creature it gave the old
man enough time to take a sharp turn
around a corner and find a hiding spot
amongst the other tents and broken down
cars the seasoned Explorer had one last
trick up his sleeve and he prayed that
it would bring an end to this terrifying
encounter as scp-682 sniffed the air
searching for him the old man produced
another bottle of unbridled energy this
time derived from the same kind of
dimensional riff found on level 21. he
hurled it towards the reptile not a
moment too soon and watched in awe as
the bottle exploded the floor and
ceilings began to crumble as arcs of
energy surrounded 682. what is this
scp-682 thought feeling itself being
pulled from this reality and into
another seconds later the reptile was
gone in a flash of energy the old man
wiped his brow in relief that was close
wherever 682 was after being warped by
the dimensional Terror this particular
Explorer had managed to escape its wrath
for now but would others be so lucky
scp-682 found itself hurtling through an
unstable dimensional Rift and into some
fresh new hell 682 Rose from the dirt
and mulched beneath its body and found
itself on level 23 of the back rooms
which had the distinguishing
characteristics of being a spherical
planetoid formed from the interlocking
of countless towering trees it was
commonly known as the Petrified garden
and it was the first of many back rooms
levels that took the form of a globe
rather than an infinite maze I know that
it is hard to imagine a spherical world
because in our native reality the planet
Earth is a flat plane with ice walls on
the side
just kidding the Flat Earth model is an
inaccurate and roundly discredited
conception of cosmography without any
empirical evidence to support it could
you imagine if we were peddling this
kind of conspiratorial fiction here in a
YouTube video anyway back to our
regularly scheduled program about an
indestructible lizard traveling through
another dimension that's real nearly all
of the tree specimens present on level
23 had equivalent species that were
native to the front rooms AKA are
reality there were birch trees Cedars
redwoods White Oaks and many more common
types intertwined with trees that were
either long extinct or never before seen
on Earth 2682 a tree was a tree but then
again the ketter class SCP wasn't known
for having a deep and abiding respect
for nature right now what was flashing
through its reptilian head was a need to
inflict violence preferably on the old
Wanderer that unwarped scp-682 to level
23 but really any entity that crossed
its path was liable to get a taste of
the old Ma and Claw thankfully the back
rooms had a habit of deploying wave
after wave of bizarre creatures from who
knows where not more than a couple
levels ago 682 had been faced with a
veritable Army of these backrooms
entities and came out of the fight
Victorious by this point the hard to
destroy reptile was well acquainted with
death rats death moths clumps smilers
and Hounds all of which were no doubt
lurking somewhere in the Woodwork of
level 23 you can't run you can hide but
I will find you and destroy you
682 was on the hunt once again walking
through the entangled mess of trees like
an Unstoppable engine of Rage it had
certainly been some time since 682 had
encountered an entirely new entity
though it wasn't exactly clamoring for a
new lore expansion since 682 was a being
that despised all forms of life and
wanted to destroy it the reptile had the
Outlook of the less entities that were
present throughout the back rooms the
better so when the Volpe appeared before
682 the anomalous monster was less than
thrilled but I'll bet that you viewers
at home are excited to get to know a
brand new backrooms entity after such a
long wait so why don't we give you the
Carfax
um car fox fox facts we're going to tell
you about the Volpe now which no matter
how it appears to the untrained eye is
not in fact a fox the volpe's entity
number is 119 and its name comes from
the Corsican word for fox but I must
once again clarify this entity is not
actually a fox the easiest way is to
distinguish a Volpe from its more
well-known counterpart in the front
rooms are the abnormally elongated snout
and the secondary tail volpes have been
known to dwell almost exclusively in
levels of the back rooms that display
forest-like characteristics which one
could imagine would be very few of them
but genuinely who knows at this point
there could be an infinite number of
infinite forests infinitely scattered
across infinite layers of the back rooms
and if that were to be the case there
would be an infinite number of volpes in
all of them an entity 119 and its
natural habitat will dwell within a
Subterranean Den where the vulpate digs
itself in order to provide shelter and
protect itself from low temperatures
these dens can be unusually elaborate
and may comprise multiple branching
tunnels and security measures such as a
collection of Twigs that can alert the
Volpe to Intruders when they are
Disturbed this complexity is somewhat
warranted because the Lopez stores a
plentiful stash of food deep within the
den making it very unlikely for them to
go hungry these volpes are rather clever
aren't they perhaps they are but not
quite clever enough to avoid being
effortlessly crushed by a cp682 as it
brought its two front claws down on top
of the entity better luck next time
entity 119 not that there will be a next
time
scp-682 continued to move along the
surface of the planetoid and eventually
entered into a cavern created by the
intertwining Roots delving beneath level
23's forested crust the reptile found
itself inside of a Glow Room an
underground chamber lit by the
bioluminescence of glow worm-like
entities which had been given the name
Gardner's saris as their name would
imply these creatures constantly made
noises that sounded vaguely like the
word sorry these pitiful worms crawled
around the glowing fungi and smaller
Flora making their signature noises and
scp-68 B2 was absolutely not sorry to
messily devour every one of The
Gardener's saris the room was much
darker with the absence of The
Gardener's sarees but only temporarily
so as scp-682 was able to take on the
bioluminescent glow of its own and light
its way deeper beneath the surface of
level 23. it soon entered an area of
ancient ruins that seemed man-made yet
overgrown with moss and long abandoned
scp-682 had seen sparing evidence
throughout the back rooms of abandoned
human civilizations but the ruins of
level 23 were closer in appearance to
the structures built by the people of
682's native reality they were similar
to some of the great wonders of the
world but with fundamental differences
for example a number of new replicas of
the Pyramids of Giza deviated in shape
Enough From The Originals to be arranged
in a spherical formation the other
buildings found within this area of
level 23 had obvious counterparts but
none of the architecture represented
modern design line trans the most
advanced buildings were equivalent to
buildings in the front rooms constructed
in and before 1000 A.D in and among the
ancient ruins could be found a large
variety of artifacts all of which seemed
equally to be shoddy knockoffs of relics
from the front rooms
scp-682 stepped across the fragile
Pottery in clay Idols quietly satisfied
at the site of many telltale signs of
civilizational collapse and the utter
lack of living humans there were a few
clumps fiddling around in the rubble but
682 didn't let them get away with
existing in its presence you Dreadful
rejects can return but not Jerry how
disgusting I miss Jerry
scp-682's thoughts turned to its lost
companion entity 7 the blue Hyacinth
Macaw had been the only tolerable
presence that 682 had known within the
back rooms and sadly in the hard to
destroy reptile's entire existence this
hateful and terrific being had never
understood the meaning of love and
compassion until Jerry had appeared to
it it was possible that they would never
meet again and this somber realization
weighed heavily on 682's mind the big
lizard continued through the glow room
and noticed an unusual plaque scrawled
in rough Latin while 682 was not an Avid
Reader its adaptive capabilities allowed
it to translate the message that was
left behind by whatever beings
previously inhabited level 23. it read
we dedicate this great sphere of Giza to
the great Gardener in hopes of
forgiveness for the great wrong we have
committed already our purple eyes have
turned green we have started to return
to the Earth forgotten and overgrown our
only hope is that alone and petrified we
will not disappear as Architects of a
failed project the first sentence was
apparently a clear reference to the
spherical Great Pyramid that 682 had
come across earlier but the significance
of the rest remained a mystery however
these failed Architects were there was
no trace of them left on this planetoid
682 didn't warn them of course and it
felt almost content to know that
whatever Grand project they had in store
had crumbled leaving their ruins
occupied by the likes of clumps it
served them right for existing for
attempting to create something their
sadness was proof enough that they'd
learned their lesson and had long since
faded into The Ether maybe that's all
the back rooms was in the end a series
of failed attempts at building worlds
that would ultimately be forgotten when
time and people moved on to bigger and
better projects
scp-682 mused on these thoughts as it
proceeded down into the very core of
level 23. to its surprise aside of
remarkable Beauty awaited the reptile
within their countless Roots found and
embraced each other surrounding the
gravity-locked orb of luminescent water
an Apparent Source of light nutrients
and ultimately life for The Greenery of
level 23. this was the heart of the
level and it was fittingly known as the
heart of water 682 stared for a long
time at the heart of water and it wasn't
really sure why naturally occurring
wonders like this held little appeal to
the reptile but somehow this one was
different perhaps it was because at this
moment
scp-682 truly realized how far it had
come from its containment cell at site
19. it had endured every hardship the
back rooms had thrown its way and now it
was looking upon the heart of water an
object that it could never have fathomed
existing and could never have reached
until it truly became free and
uninhibited no longer subject to the
whims of the foundation then the most
unusual thing happened to scp-682 a
function of its physiology that was so
rarely seen or utilized
scp-682 shed a single tier it flowed
Down The Reptilian creature snout and
then arrested by the gravitational pull
of the heart of water floated away and
vanished into the liquid mass this was a
private moment for 682 that not even
Jerry was here to see and yet the fall
of this tear may have solidified a
change in 682 it was a mixed feeling of
Independence and Detachment for most of
its journey through the back rooms
scp-682 had felt an urge to completely
clear the abyss and show no mercy to
every entity that existed within it
whether it manifested as determination
or spite that urge had been the
overriding feeling that had driven
scp-682 to progress through every level
of the back room's in sequential order
but these new feelings made it realize
that even that would be playing into the
hands of the back rooms
scp-682 once thought that the back rooms
were cold and in different place like an
endless universe that arbitrarily
created and destroyed all the beings
that existed in it without purpose or
reason but that was not the case and in
fact it seemed more likely that the
complete opposite was true the back
rooms was imbued by its creators with so
much obvious intention that it was
practically a sentient being the back
rooms was heavily invested in taking
itself seriously and revering every
detail that made each level distinctive
and giving every entity and Hazards a
specific method of ruining the
experience of all Wanderers that pass
through
scp-682 could now see the back rooms for
what it actually was a desperate
pathetic thing clawing for attention but
forever doomed to be obscure and unloved
it was even sadder than an indifferent
Universe because it was a constructed
universe that had no greater meaning
than to be acknowledged for simply being
something where nothing once was it
could even be said that the words on the
plaque of the Glow Room in level 23 were
the ultimate admission of hopelessness
and that there was nothing waiting for
SCP 682 or any other Wanderer but the
similar statements of failed Architects
all the way down and that was to saying
nothing of all the once ambitious Works
within the back rooms that had been
erased by happenstance who could even
say that the numbers that correspond to
backrooms levels that scp-682 had
already traversed were even the correct
ones there could potentially be one or
more entirely different numerical
sequences to the levels that were
equally as true to the ones who labeled
them as such if the back rooms didn't
want to be known to be documented to be
expanded upon I doubt that such rigid
assignments of numbers would have been
acceptable by its creators it wasn't
realizing all of this that 682
remembered the elderly explorer that had
flung him into level 23. while it was
true that things hadn't gone the
reptile's way in that encounter it was
questionable who the real winner was
when it was clear that the man had
dedicated the best years of his life to
researching and wandering the back rooms
sure he had mastered some neat parlor
tricks with the magical items native to
this reality but to be a master of the
back rooms was no better than the 682
declaring itself Master of the acid tank
in its prior containment cell that
elderly man with the trinkets could keep
his hollow Victory because 682 would
still be alive and kicking when that
human's bones were nothing more than set
dressing left behind and some heretofore
untouched level of the back rooms his
fate would be the same as the rest of
the back rooms eventually a joke with no
real setup and punchline forgotten to
attempt to complete or destroy or
uncover the Mysteries behind the back
rooms was exactly what the loathsome
cluster of disjointed Concepts wanted
and 682 was done with giving this
liminal nightmare the satisfaction
sometimes the only way to win a game is
not to play the game at all and that was
precisely how
scp-682 would approach the back rooms
from here on out maybe it would be Trump
forever or maybe it would be sent home
at any moment but caring about the
outcome either way was a waste of
precious brain power there was only one
way to deal with the desperate neediness
of the back rooms and that was embracing
and becoming internally the cold
indifferent universe that it could never
be and that was now what scp-682 would
be enlightened and fully detached from
this reality it Strode out of the heart
of water and into another Glow Room only
to find an outpost of major explorers
group waiting for it let's try something
new
scp-682 easily broke down the door and
found itself surrounded by panicked
humans many of them were wielding pump
action squirt guns and had begun
spraying 682 with what seemed to be
almond flavored water 682 didn't react
to these attacks at all and slowly
wandered towards the humans with no
particular urgency pardon my intrusion
682 said grinning with much politeness
as it could muster do any of you fine
people know the way back to level nine
the humans shuddered Unsure how to
answer they stood in their silence until
one brave soul came forth and spoke to
scp-682 there's a Gateway inside this
Outpost that can take you to the next
level said the Explorer but it appears
to be one way since whatever was on the
other side appears to no longer exist
what do you mean it no longer exists 682
asked trying against its better judgment
to make sense of the circumstances the
Explorer nodded and went on seemingly
motivated by fear we mean it's no longer
part of any current Archive of backrooms
related phenomenon and its name will
likely be erased soon not that having
the name would provide any consolation
after all there's still no telling what
is on the other side and if it was ever
what the explorers who reported on it
claimed it was now this was an
unsettling development 682 had only just
started to come to terms with the
instability of reality in the back rooms
and the notion that a level could be
totally wiped from existence and leave
behind a gateway to absolutely nowhere
was chilling even to the immortal lizard
what would happen to 682 if the reptile
stepped through the Gateway would it
find itself in the place that the
Gateway was once and still is connected
to or would it simply disappear into the
void as if it were never there at all
because this was the back rooms there
was always a third option too as well as
countless others that find all logic so
now the question facing scp-682 was to
step into the unknown or to remain here
in level 23 with the major explorers
group it was a difficult decision to say
the least the humans looked on as
scp-682 carefully weighed its options
eventually the reptile opened its mouth
to speak on the matter I'll give it some
thought 682 said you have been very
helpful for a disgusting human so for
the time being I will permit you to
continue your meaningless existence and
I guess that includes the rest of your
Outpost uh oh that's um well thank you
um yeah thank you the human stammered
682 turned and began to walk towards the
heart of water it intended to take its
time with its Choice since progress
through the levels of the back rooms was
no longer something that the reptile
would be pursuing with Reckless abandon
it heavily considered going back on its
words and slaughtering all the members
of the major explorers group in this
Outpost as it had done in all the other
outposts but it was plain to see that a
human trapped in the back rooms barely
qualified as living because nothing
could be worse than being permanently
stuck in the torturous Abyss 682 had no
idea whether pure spite towards them was
what made sparing their lives so
compelling or something else had
motivated that decision but regardless
the hard to destroy reptile did not
destroy the humans of level 23. as it
exited the base the brave human that had
spoken to it called out wait lizard I
have to know what are you 682 stopped
and stared at the human it's just we
need to catalog you I've never seen
anything else in the back rooms like you
682 breathed out it sounded almost like
a surrender I am entity six eight two
after those words left its jaws 682
wandered away from the human until it
was once again sitting by the heart of
water he didn't think about the choice
or the Gateway immediately for now
entity 682 was peacefully reminiscing
back to the quality time it had spent
with entity 7 Jerry from this pointless
and nonsensical Place known as the back
rooms they would meet again that was the
one thing 682 could be sure of somehow
some way they would meet again an
indeterminate amount of time later over
24 levels away from the reptile in the
front rooms the reality which it had no
clipped out of so many days and weeks
ago the researchers of the SCP
Foundation had gathered together and
were celebrating an unforeseen event
almost all of them had long since given
up hope that it could ever happen and
yet here they were standing before the
o5 council and all the illustrious
scientists and soldiers that had worked
to make this day a reality everyone
watched in total amazement as the heads
of the foundation declared the cutter
class
scp-682 hard to destroy reptile
permanently neutralized
Vines branches and tendrils grab at
682's wriggling body as the skinless
grinning face of the skeleton Queen
their stand she is in total control for
one of the first times ever 682 has
encountered a threat who might be too
powerful for even its strength and
adaptability to surpass how could such
an impossible circumstance come to pass
lost in an endless abyss of liminal
realities separated from its closest
Companions and officially declared to be
neutralized by the SCP Foundation The
Immortal reptilian entity known as 682
continues its incomprehensible journey
through the back rooms 682 had explored
over 20 different levels of the back
rooms from vast oceans to Lost Cities to
even mind warping spaces that evoked
distant childhood memories very little
if any of what 682 had encountered could
be described as fun or adventurous in
682's mind the back rooms was a
nightmare controlled by malicious forces
that only wanted to bring harm to the
creature the lizard had faced scores of
violent entities ranging from low-level
fodder like clumps smilers and death
moths spear-wielding mini bosses like
tiny and Argus and one particularly
crafty and well-equipped Explorer for
all of these encounters and the
dimension hopping hijinks that came with
them 682 had become enduring and
resilient the uncontrollable rage and
disgust for life that had defined 682's
personality during its time in
containment had gradually subsided into
an almost enlightened state of
determination
the will to be its own Master decide its
own destiny and to travel the back rooms
not as a conqueror but as an entity
seeking freedom for its sake it spent a
long time contemplating its purpose in
the cryptic ruins of the Petrified
Garden on level 23 before making a new
effort to travel between layers of the
back rooms as one might expect the next
level that 682 was able to access was
level 24 known by some as the study but
better known by its locals as the moon
even as far as levels in the back rooms
go level 24 was an unusual concept for
682 to understand at first the walkable
portion of the level appeared to be a
plastic model of a moon blown up to
colossal proportions the moon was a part
of a scale model of the solar system and
was situated inside a Victorian era
study of impossible size the exact
details of the massive room were hard to
see given the anomalous blurry filter
that appeared to impede the vision of
those who tried to look away from the
Moon
no consistent theme with the previous
levels vague and inexplicable properties
and a seemingly random resemblance to
human-made structures
classic backrooms 682 mused in the
distance expanse of the study entity 682
thought that it saw a Titanic human man
in a tuxedo pulling a book from one of
the shelves and sitting down to read it
this blurry giant was known simply as
Buford and it was the only unique entity
to this level of the back rooms the
craters and riffs of the moon were home
to swarms of death moths and clumps
though there were noticeably not as many
of these hostile entities as on previous
levels 682 regarded the presence of
these familiar foes as something of a
novelty given the amount of time it had
spent on the relatively safe level 23.
the more things change the more they
stay just as disgusting while success
City 2 was not exactly pleased with
having to share the same reality as
these infernal things it was not about
to rush in and start taking names if the
researchers at the foundation could see
682 now they might assume that the
reptile had been reformed of its violent
ways this was not the case 682 had come
to accept that these creatures had no
real ecosystem or drive to propagate
themselves as other life did the
mechanics of their existence seemed to
be limited to the mere fact that they
were extensions of the back rooms itself
obstacles placed in the path of
explorers to thwart their progress they
were more like the enemies of a video
game than sentient life forms and 682
had come to believe that fighting them
would be doing exactly what the back
rooms wanted it to do if 682 needed to
defend itself it would absolutely fight
back against these stock entities but by
now it was obvious that they were not a
real
there were better games to play in the
arcade of life and 682 was not feeling
particularly flush with tokens
appropriately enough the next level that
682 arrived at level 25 was filled with
a wide selection of arcade machines once
again the back rooms had thrown another
devious curveball in the direction of
682 the hard to destroy reptile was
reminded once again of just how
unpredictable the variations in theme
could be between levels true to its
retro aesthetic level 25 seemed to be
covered in a thin layer of dust the
arcade machines themselves were damaged
and broken down the few that did seem
functional were not equipped with any
game that 682 was familiar with then
again 682 was not exactly an avid gamer
perhaps the sorry state of the arcade
would be explained by the level being
where the 80s went to die or more likely
by the fact no human Explorer had made
it this far into the back room comes in
quite some time the lack of humans in an
environment designed for them was hardly
a new occurrence inside of the back
rooms and as usual the general ideas
seem to be that something that was
usually normal like a hotel or an office
was presented in a way that made it
inconvenient an arcade where no games
could be played was certainly a bummer
but considering that it's several layers
farther down than a level where
explorers were forced to confront their
traumatic pasts and another level that
threatened all Explorers with
ever-shifting extreme environments the
plight of being stuck in a defunct
arcade was a bit of an underwhelming
concept 682 had long since accepted that
there was no linear difficulty curve to
the back rooms and given that this place
was also devoid of entities level 25
didn't seem to have much to offer the
reptile with no other options 682
decided to try one of the arcade
machines naturally it didn't carry any
quarters on its being but that was only
a minor quibble to a creature as
adaptable as 682 I can do anything as
682 approached one of the functional
arcade machines it developed a
quarter-shaped skin tag on the tip of
its snout similar to the knobby growth
of a male Geral crocodile it extended
this growth towards the coin slot on a
wire thin appendage as if it were an
actual quarter 682 did its best
impression of placing a quarter inside
of an arcade machine once the machine
blinked to life 682 retracted its
organic quarter the bright screen of the
cabinet began to shuffle rapidly through
numbers like a slot machine it did this
for several minutes until landing on the
number 28 Sparks of energy course
through the arcade cabinet and a sudden
burst of light Wist 682 several levels
ahead 682 could see a tunnel of light on
all sides as it flew through the liminal
space between liminal spaces it was able
to perceive a hint of level 2 6 a
seemingly ordinary apartment building
and level 27 an innocent looking hot
spring inside of a cave both Concepts
were old hat at this point so 682 didn't
feel too bad about skipping them besides
it was a free being now and what was
Freer than breaking the rules and
skipping a few levels unless the back
rooms was hoping it would do that but
there was no time to think about the
inscruciable intentions of the Abyss
creators because 682 had reached the
other side of the light tunnel and had
been deposited into level 28 a dimension
with a navy blue sky and a single large
Castle on a hill the only Landmark 682
moved towards the castle and was greeted
by the sound of great Thunder above dark
storm clouds began to fill the sky as
rain poured down onto the forested
valley surrounding the keep while now
ordinary storm would deter being as
powerful as 682 the howling winds and
flashes of Lights signaled that this
weather was anything but ordinary the
reptile naturally decided to continue
into the only available shelter the
castle it barged in through one of the
walls in an effort to hide itself from
the elements it soon learned that it was
not alone a foreboding figure approached
from the darkness of the keep clad head
to toe in colorful blue armor who goes
there answer me you scaly Nate
feeling a bit spicy 682 decided to break
out an old favorite threat what good
does it do for a lamb to know the name
of its butcher I am simply passing
through you're just one more lifeless
husk dreamed up by the back rooms so
leave me be and return to your dull
routine of scaring weak humans foul
Beast the blue Knight said I would never
scare humans on purpose I happen to
quite respect them as a matter of fact I
have met a particularly good human who
taught me so many wonderful things
say you've met a good human 682 asked
other than the exception of the Dead I
cannot think of any humans that are
worthy of existence let alone good well
then you don't know Sarah the blue
Knight said seemingly in a state of
rising emotional distress the storm
outside began to grow in intensity in
response to the Blue Knights provoked
reaction 682 found this somewhat
intriguing and decided to push the
armored figure a bit further is she your
girlfriend
682 taunted 682 was becoming
simultaneously more amused and disgusted
by this blue Knight as the interaction
went on it was clear that the blue
Knight was a bit of a lunatic and
definitely a soft-hearted being though
as 682 pondered his words an odd feeling
of realization washed over the reptile
was the current situation regarding
682's lost traveling companion entity 7
Jerry not dissimilar from what the night
was going through in regards to this
human named Sarah 682 had learned much
about the back rooms during his time
traveling with the blue Hyacinth Macaw
and did miss the avian entity very much
the idea that Jerry may have forgotten
about 682 and might be on adventures
somewhere else made 682 almost feel
regretful suddenly tormenting this
overly sensitive Knight didn't seem to
be that much fun to 682 all at once the
reptile wanted out of this level so he
ordered the Knight to give him an exit
the blue Knight shook his head for a bit
but ultimately relented he led 682 to an
archway deep in the castle made of solid
bones it was a dimensional portal like
many of those seen in the back rooms and
it was carved with a number 32. these
portal shall take you to the forest of
the skeleton Queen on level 32. it is a
dangerous place where you will almost
certainly meet your demise the skeleton
Queen is not known for her Hospitality
the force of the skeleton Queen was
about what one might expect from its
name a dark and gloomy Woodland beneath
a starless sky and a crescent moon of
course there was also the countless
skeletons floating amongst the trees to
give the level some personality all of
them seemed somewhat alive but like many
of the back room's other tricks this may
have only been an illusion it will do
before 682 could even fully take in the
scenery it could see another entity
moving between the trees it seemed to be
a human woman in a Victorian dress and
skeletal face paint she appeared to
Jester to 682 beckoning the reptile into
the forest there was nothing to lose yet
so 682 took to the mysterious woman's
provocation and followed her not too far
down the path 682 lost sight of this
strange human woman it was as if she had
been there a moment and was gone the
next 682 pondered the the odd nature of
this encounter and decided to turn back
around and follow a different path as
soon as the reptile turned the woman
appeared before it again but this time
her overall form was more Sinister she
was tall and gaunt with hardly any skin
in the white of her bones shown
ominously in the Moonlight she smiled an
evil smile and without a single word she
snapped her fingers causing the entire
Forest to immediately turn on 682 it was
an attack more sudden and more complete
than any 682 had ever experienced there
was no chance to censor hostility no
room to adapt or to react the trees took
hold of six City too and in a display of
immense Supernatural power that defined
all logic tour 682's very Spirit out of
its physical form and dragged it into
the darkness beneath the forest in its
long and miserable life The Immortal
reptile 682 had endured every punish
form of damage in creation But Here and
Now in the back rooms for the very first
time 682 would not have the luxury of
its hard to destroy infinitely adaptable
body it was now a helpless disembodied
Soul without any means to defend itself
the perfect play thing for the skeleton
Queen herself forged by the darkest
whims of powers Beyond reality
scp-682's body was a temple to All
Things feared by Mortals with extreme
regenerative abilities unparalleled
adaptive power and formidable features
that surpass any non-anomalous apex
predator and the vast majority of
anomalous ones and yet on level 32 of
the back rooms 682 has now been
separated from its indestructible Body
by it possibly even stronger being the
powerful backrooms entity known as
skeleton Queen who rules levels 32 with
a bony fist has exerted the power of her
domain and has disembodied the soul of
682 rendering the malicious reptile or
rather its Spirit completely helpless
nobody would be coming to save 682's
soul from its current predicament of
course 682 was not the kind to rely on
others and was more surprised by the
fact that it had a mortal Soul the
closest thing to an all-powerful God in
the front rooms
scp-343 was recorded as being unable to
even interact with 682 a fact that the
reptile itself was only later made aware
of because it likewise could not
perceive 343 the notion of residing as a
pure Consciousness in either heaven or
hell should they exist was never
something 682 believed had a chance of
happening as if my existence would ever
be extinguished anyway the rules of the
back rooms were mysterious different
from 682's native reality so it was
possible that the Labyrinthian
Dimensions to find what a soul was in a
different way but there was a second
option that 682 was considering not in
the Forefront of its mind but deep down
in the place of vulnerability which it
had become more in touch with as it
traveled in the back rooms that second
option was the possibility that the sum
total of 682's experiences in the back
rooms had somehow imbued the creature
with a soul or ignited the dormant spark
of its Soul causing it to grow to full
size like a spectral flame surely the
fact that there was some Essence to its
current form a self that existed outside
of the confines of its monstrous
physical shape was proof enough that 682
had become or always was more than the
sum of its creature Parts I will not be
anyone's Pawn to manipulate I have a
soul belongs to myself alone
that knowledge alone kept 682 from
surrendering to its fate as the skeleton
Queen's plaything ever since it had
escaped the foundation its goal had been
to maintain that unassailable freedom
like the old AI that it once befriended
in its native reality 682 was now
thoroughly convinced that it was not
merely a machine but instead of Free
Will being with a right to exist outside
of containment the once undefeated Beast
would reclaim its record no matter what
it took it refused to turn away its
future potential by becoming a permanent
resident of the forest of the skeleton
Queen The Entity herself was still in
her larger more imposing form she
carried 682's Soul deeper into the
forest leaving her tree Warriors to
Devour the reptiles abandoned physical
body 682 knew better than to attempt to
converse with the skeleton queen as she
seemed to be mute possibly by choice it
chose instead to keep its mind active
searching for an opening to make an
escape the queen soon found a skeleton
floating amongst the branches which
unlike most of the others didn't have
glowing eyes
with a single graceful motion of her
hand she placed the spectral fire of
682's Soul inside the skull of the
floating skeleton in a Flash 682 found
its Consciousness inside of a new body
the skeleton itself this wasn't an ideal
form compared to what 682 was used to
but it could feel that Mobility was
possible in these skeleton Limbs and
that was a far cry from being a
disembodied spirit this body is weak but
it will have to do now I must bide my
time for that opening 682 the skeleton
remained almost motionless as the
skeleton queen admired her new
acquisition a few moments later she
shrank back to her more humanoid form
and danced away into the world 682 now
had the Glade to itself and it
remembered well where its former body
had been left once the skeleton Queen
was completely out of view skeleton 682
leaped down from its Heights of the tree
and landed on the ground it took off
running towards the place where its Soul
had been removed planning to assimilate
itself back into its old body I have to
become myself again then that disgusting
skeleton Queen will regret crossing my
path as if responding to six City two's
thoughts of Revenge the skeleton Queen
danced back into its path skeleton 682
froze in place and was caught off guard
as the skeleton Queen snapped her
fingers and caused several more
skeletons to fall from the upper
branches all at once the skeletons began
to dance not knowing another way to move
past in its current form 682 Soul made
the skeleton body it was inhabiting
begin to dance this caused the skeleton
Queen to make the first vocalization
that 682 had heard her make a deep
feminine laugh she extended her hands
and took hold of the skeleton that
housed 682's Soul leading it into a
ballroom
682 bitterly mumbled about this whole
thing being humiliating ah so he can
speak said the skeleton Queen what an
interesting Soul you are 682 was not
expecting the skeleton Queen to sound so
human but considering that the rulers of
other levels at 682 visited were also
capable of speech her attempts to
communicate were a sign that she was not
as different from the other backrooms
entities as she might have seemed for
now she wasn't in her most monstrous
form and that meant she didn't feel
threatened and in that state of blissful
ignorance was exactly where 682 wanted
her 682 when this new skeleton form
protested that his soul was not of this
Dimension he was a powerful being from
another Universe one that should not be
messed with the queen smiled to her 682
Soul was no different from any of the
others that she'd captured in her
skeleton-filled playground naturally 682
found being compared to other beings
disgusting
insulting again the queen was merely
amused she said I witnessed the plight
of lost goblings fell beasts and The
Brood spawn of the outer darkness and
its many incarnations this forest and my
power over it are immune to the stain of
Scarlet here there is only room for
black and white 682 chuckled in its
skeleton frame so was the skeleton Queen
the true ruler of the back rooms you
still don't get it there are no back
rooms nothing
the queen had started to become a bit
more ominous in her tone 682 almost
missed the timber of humanity that was
once there she went on describing in
detail she couldn't know every step of
the journey that brought 682 to this
place she spoke of the close bond that
682 had formed with entity 7 Jerry of
the places of Tranquility that made sick
City to feel something close to
happiness and of the victories against
all the Hostile entities at 682 had
bested she described it as a dream or a
poem a fleeting and Beautiful Eulogy for
a soul now freed of all obligations
freed from purpose freed from Life 682
watched as the body had hoped to return
to was pulled deep beneath the surface
of the forest the skeleton Queen
continued to lead her skeletons and
dance it was a dance of surrender a
gloss of the inevitable Doom of All
Souls 682 was starting to forget which
skeleton and its Soul was even inside of
anymore anger began to coerce through
what remained of
scp-682's Consciousness this cannot be
How I Meet My Demise I will not face
such a disgusting fate and then just
then it all clicked 682 realized that
its Soul wasn't inside any of the
skeletons at all because it had been
lying dormant somewhere else somewhere
far more expected the skeleton Queen
hadn't ripped out the essence of its
Spirit but instead had fallen for a
trick that even this piece of 682's
Consciousness hadn't known about
of course as if I could have a soul
beneath the Earth of the woods
scp-682's reptilian body began to stir
it was now connected to the soul that
dwelled within the skeleton Queen's
Forest a soul created through the heart
to destroy reptiles indomitable ability
to adapt to any and we do mean any
adverse circumstance its powers of
adaptation went beyond the physical and
into even the metaphysical it could for
lack of a better description forcibly
evolve it's
well the skeleton Queen was capable of
manipulating The Souls of human
explorers controlling the entirety of
682's Mind was far beyond her
capabilities so in response to her
Supernatural curse that removes Souls
682 broke off a tiny piece of its
Consciousness to serve as a decoy or
more accurately a parasite that was
slowly infecting level 32 The Forest of
the skeleton Queen and now was the real
opening for 682 to overcome the control
of the latest backrooms entity to
believe that it was up to the challenge
of destroying the heart to destroy
reptile 682 gloated that the skeleton
Queen had never truly known what it was
up against the dance of the skeletons
ceased as the queen became aware of
Rumblings of 682's original body digging
its way back towards the surface I am
not simply another child of the Scarlet
King I am more than my bloodline more
than whatever destiny he was chosen for
me I am a greater threat than even the
foundation knew but you'll know the
monster that was as cp682 emerged from
the ground biting into the skeleton
Queen and immobilizing her one skeleton
stepped forth approaching the queen then
another and soon all of them 682 was now
in control of the skeleton Queen's
entire realm the soul decoy having
fulfilled its purpose skeleton Queen 682
said through the body of a skeleton a
part of me thought you really could have
been the one to bring me down
but I have to thank you because now you
have shown me the truth of the back
rooms and the truth is anything can be
the back rooms the skeleton Queen cried
out in pain as 682's Jaws sunk deeper
into her she tried to take her
intimidating monster form but even that
was not enough for pry herself free from
the reptile's grasp in your memory I
will become the thing that I once hated
I will become the back rooms as it spoke
those words 682's adaptation Advanced to
an entirely new level as it had
demonstrated in so many cross-tests 682
devoured and assimilated the properties
of the threat it was currently facing in
a moment of sheer willpower and freakish
resilience 682 absorbed the skeleton
Queen and her huge force of skeletons
into its body level 32 buckled and
warped under the command of a new master
hostile entities from every level felt a
terrifying disturbance in the back rooms
as one of the great level rulers was
toppled at the same time 682's
perception of the back rooms changed
dramatically and rapidly it found itself
on level zero once more clearing through
entity after entity in a vengeful
Stampede then minutes later it was
cycling through every level at
incredible speed drawing in the essence
of the back rooms itself and becoming
something greater than either
scp-682 or the back
on the great shift in the liminal Abyss
subsided 682 had taken its most powerful
form yet its reptilian bodies still
existed but its Soul or at least what
had become of the Soul fragment it had
created had expanded into a wholly new
level of the back rooms an amalgamation
of every level that 682 had ever touched
welcome to level
682 the hard to destroy reptile was now
more than an entity dwelling within the
Sea of altered realities it had become
an irrevocable element of the back rooms
a being that would soon be feared as a
master among the dimension rulers of
many worlds but it did have plenty more
levels to conquer first
scp-682 was once at the mercy of the
liminal Abyss known as the back rooms
but now the hard to destroy reptile had
become a master of the back rooms after
after absorbing the essence of the
skeleton Queen along with several other
powerful backrooms entities
scp-682 had become powerful enough to
create its own level of the back rooms
level 682 if you cannot beat the back
rooms become the back rooms in its
latest adapted form 682 was able to
command the lesser entities of the back
rooms such as clumps death moths and
Hounds these entities were now at the
beck and call of 682 and could be
deployed at moments notice to Savage
trespassers on 682's level while it was
nearly unfathomable to believe that any
human Explorer could survive the long
journey from Level 0 to level 682
Challengers would soon arrive to attempt
to snatch the proverbial Crown from
682's reptilian head the death of the
skeleton Queen had upset the balance of
the back rooms and now there were
countless other supernatural beings that
wanted a taste of the scrappy newcomer
the first two Warriors to arrive were
the infamous spear using humanoids
entity 74 Argos and entity 720 tiny
other than a shared weapon of choice and
a mutual hatred for scp-682 these two
entities had little in common but the
sting of their previous defeats at the
claws of their hated rival had compelled
the two to make their way to level 682
and faced the lizard once more Argos
bellowed as he entered into the
devastated Wasteland of level 682 he had
appeared first accompanied by a
specially trained retinue of human
soldiers in tactical gear the eyes of
Argos each one wielded a lesser replica
of their Immortal Leader's signature
Spear and all were ready for battle
faced with these Intruders all scp-682
could do was laugh wickedly its own Army
of hostile entities stood at attention
leering at the human
entity 74
Argos
scp-682 greeted its visitor even without
eyes in that swollen head of yours you
must see that you cannot win this Argos
roared that 682 was a sinner and his
judgment was here Argos pointed his
Spear and the eyes of Argos charge
towards 682 who in turn raised a claw
and signaled its own forces to meet the
eyes on the field of combat level 682 of
the back rooms was now a battlefield
human soldiers and entities were
clashing in pinched Warfare Argos broke
through the front lines and turned his
spear on 682 the reptile merely grinned
through all of its teeth as argos's
spear was deflected effortlessly off its
hide Argo struck again and again but it
seemed that the eyeless giant had
totally underestimated 682's new form
this was not going to be the same fight
as the previous time the two had met
with the level of strength that the
reptile had amassed it might not even be
anything that could be considered a
fight at least not if it remained a
one-on-one battle fortunately for Argos
the other of the back room's spear Duo
was about to make a splash literally a
gateway to level seven the Endless Ocean
opened above the battlefield causing an
Untold quantity of water to flow into
the war zone of level 682 it was chaos
as both Argos and 682's minions were
swept up in the current and drowned out
Argos was frustrated at the sudden loss
of his army but 682 couldn't care less
about what happened to backrooms
entities that had temporarily bought
themselves a bit more time in existence
by pledging loyalty to their reptile
Master it was after all only a matter of
time before 682 had gotten sick of them
and destroyed the miserable entities on
a whim Sirius contenders only your our
entrance was sinful Argo spat towards
tiny as the Rushing Water submerged him
my entrance like everything I do was
perfect tiny scoffed now are you going
to Aid in my revenge against this
loathsome Beast are you going to be
sanctimonious as usual the spear Duo
acknowledged each other and putting
aside their differences in a temporary
Alliance though for 682 in an attempt to
overwhelm the hard to destroy reptile
the tips of both Spears collided with
682 and managed to push the creature a
short distance across the now submerged
landscape above its level in retaliation
682 traded its claws for a number of
flexible tentacles that were able to
push off the ground and Propel the level
Master towards its two adversaries it
grappled Argos with its long flexible
arms and swung him against the solid
surface of the ground the eyeless
Warrior countered by stabbing one of
682's tentacles but the club reptiles
shed the tentacle immediately and
jettison towards tiny if humanoid
attempted to stab 682 but was unable to
hit his Target as his opponent used its
tentacles to grab Tiny's body and
maneuver around him effortlessly
meanwhile Argos was just now coming to
grips with a disadvantage of its own
while on land the sin Hunter was quite
capable of sustaining countless injuries
and regenerating from the damage its
respiratory system had no way to
evacuate the water that had begun to
fill the humanoids lungs though he was
Immortal Argos was drowning even his
unlimited stamina could not prevent his
body from slowing down at this moment
both entities were unable to gain a
significant advantage over 682 moreover
the lack of cohesion between their
tactics was leaving both open to a
counter-attack this was precisely the
kind of opportunity that Sig City 2 had
been waiting for while in its prior
State the hard destroy reptile was only
able to adapt its own physique but now
that it had become one with a portion of
the back rooms it had gained the ability
to adapt its level as well in an instant
682 asserted its control over its domain
and expunged the water from Level 7 back
into the liminal nothingness between
levels while Argos could now stand back
on Solid Ground it was sluggish and
immobilized by the water in its body he
attempted to gag and force the water out
but leaving that kind of opening was a
time that entity 74 didn't have entity
720 came crashing down upon Argos
smothering The Entity having now
immobilized both of its adversaries 682
was quite proud of itself it whipped at
tiny with its fearsome tentacles adding
insult to injury with deep wounds across
the Giant's entire form spear carriers
don't belong on the main stage drawing
from the same Wellspring of power that
allow to absorb the skeleton Queen
scp-682 devoured the essence of both
entity 74 and entity 720 just like the
time before the hard to destroy reptile
went one step further than mere
consumption The Reptilian master of
Dimensions assimilated and Incorporated
elements of level 7 and level 10 into
the exponentially growing borders of
level 682 now that it was Victorious
against the two spear-wielding humanoids
682 let out a mighty Roar that echoed
throughout all the remaining levels of
the back rooms the message to all
dimensional rulers on every level was
crystal clear if they didn't come to
level 682 to challenge its Master the
reptile would bring the challenge to
each and every one of them I and the
back rooms and when my kingdom comes I
will be all there is well most of the
entities and humans on the other levels
cowered in fear there were still several
who still wish to stand and fight the
next opponent that would confront
scp-682 in an attempt to slay the
creature was none other than the blue
Knight of level 28. the brightly shining
suit of armor strode into level 682
carrying a raging Storm behind it
hurricane force winds beat down on 682
followed by an unforgiving reign of
lightning bolts the reptile weathered
the storm and struck back with a vicious
bite that crushed the armor of the blue
Knight's arm and part of his chestplate
then 682 turned like a crocodile in a
death roll inflicting even more damage
to the sentient armor with his free
Gauntlet the blue Knight pounded on
682's head bringing down even more
lightning and wind on the reptile your
storm is weak I feel disgusting having
to use my immense power to dispel it yet
again 682 manipulated its level of the
back rooms causing the storm that the
blue Knight had called to be banished
into the void between levels the blue
Knight was aghast the reason he had
always stayed on level 28 was to spare
the humans of more subtle levels from
the wrathful storm clouds that he was
known to create in his moments of
emotional outbursts it was his most
shameful curse and yet 682 had made it
disappear as simply as Morning Mist the
now powerless blue Knight could do
nothing as he too was devoured by 682
his next words were a plea for a wish
that could never come true I wish I
could have seen you one more time Sarah
like Argos and Tiny before him the blue
Knight and his corresponding level 28
had become part of 682 now 682 was
starting to get accustomed to the
feeling of devouring levels of the back
rooms The Taste was invigorating and out
of a sense of malicious initiative The
Reptilian entity went on an unplanned
Rampage through the surrounding levels
while it was nothing more than a trivial
test of the incredible power at its
disposal 682 was able to drink in more
of the back room's Essence and soon it
was beginning to reshape the liminal
Abyss itself countless entities were
nothing more than cannon fodder to the
Unstoppable machine of Destruction that
682 had become as foe after foe fell
prey to entity 682 Master of the back
rooms more of the other levels began to
disappear as they were absorbed into
level 682 the reptile was on a violent
spree at this point and could almost
imagine itself back at the foundation
painting the walls with mobile task
force agents and researchers alike in
its frenzy
scp-682 found itself once again face to
face with the plush Dino of level 18 the
despised entity 198 who served as a
guide for lost and distressed souls and
had once regarded as cp682 as the most
tormented being in existence even now
the plush Dino's instinct to reach out
to those suffering from terrible anguish
had guided it to the new and improved
682 682 had always disliked 198 and was
especially resentful that it had chosen
to appear now did its presence mean that
deep inside 682 was still suffering from
the scars of its past no I have overcome
that adapted I always do 682 stepped
forward as if to consume its next victim
but a nagging feeling stopped it from
committing to the attack if it were to
Devour the plush Dino there was a
possibility that it would also consume
level 18 a subjective realm that would
always transform to recreate the
childhood traumas of the Explorer inside
it 682 had not been afraid to face its
traumatic past during its Journey
Through the earliest layers of the back
rooms the to make the echo of those
painful memories a permanent part of its
form seemed to be a bridge too far
besides what would Jerry think of me
scp-682 caught itself thinking of entity
7 again it was frozen with indecision
unsure whether or not to devour entity
198 on the spot then a sudden blaze of
scorching Flames snapped 682 back to the
present moment this gasp of Inferno
caused the plush Dino to turn tail and
move to a different level of the back
rooms 682 was now surrounded by fire at
some distant level that it had never
seen before on the horizon stood a vast
Army of flaming beings glowing with a
solar light that gave off an
unbelievable amount of heat presiding
above all others in this militant fire
Army was the apparent leader a six-armed
bright red humanoid whose Regal features
were as imposing as the Halos of
sunflare that adorned his fingertips
this unfathomable being would soon be
682's latest and thus far greatest
Challenger he was a legend of the back
rooms and the true ruler of the warlike
dimension of level 966 The Inferno an
ancient god whose Relentless forest
fires had chased Lord wormwood and his
tree people to the brink of Extinction
the forge master who pulled the flame o
the golden from the all Brilliance and
made it his source of power this was
rajaharan the golden Kindle Prince of
fires of light o great Beast of level
682 I rajaran have heard the tales of
your glorious Conquest throughout the
liminal spaces of these back rooms I
have heard that you hail from the front
rooms and are the uncontested strongest
being from that reality I am here to
answer your summons and per your request
for a challenge
see which of us is the greater the
prince of fires moved his hands and cast
forth a merciless conflagration of
Stellar flame 682 was bathed in the fury
of a thousand suns and felt an
unthinkable Rush of pain unlike even the
sword of the Guardian from back home the
fires continued to lick its form as 682
went berserk and charged towards the
armies of rajaharan quick as the spark
of an ignited flame rajaharan
intercepted 682 and delivered a
punishing kick to the lizard's spine
fire swirled around the prince's limbs
transforming into burning weapons do not
think your quarrel is with my Army the
prince said flatly they are here to
watch rajaran swung all six of his
muscular limbs striking away at 682 with
the Divine weapons held in each 682
cried out in agony swinging a claw back
at The Prince and leaving a cut across
the Regal beings face the reptile then
stole a page from its Fallen adversaries
and transformed its tale into an
unbreakable spear striking rajaharan
with a swift attack
magnificent rajaharan smiled the battle
raged on for several hours with both
entities taking severe damage and
continuing to fight even as their bodies
were wounded with the sheer force of all
the attacks given and received as it
dragged on rajaharan revealed even
greater reserves of solaric power than
682 could have believed likewise 682
strength continued to rise as the
reptile acclimated to its ungodly strong
opponent several times 682's body was
burned entirely to Atomic Ash but it was
able to regenerate and continue the
struggle against the prince of fire and
light it was much later when rajaharan
fell the noble golden Kindle had a smile
on his face an eternal acknowledgment
that the opponent he had faced was one
truly worthy of killing him well fought
Lord of 682 I bequeath my Army to you
rule the back rooms in my Steam as his
Essence burned to Cinders the forces of
level 966 bowed their heads to 682 a
backrooms legend to destroy all
backrooms Legend now go check out
scp-018 can the Super Ball defeat
scp-682 and was scp-682 really that hard
to kill after all for even more